Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning.
Now it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Aw,
I'm just checking in on you.
I am just checking in on.
You've seen how your week's going. How's
your week going? Oh yeah. Really? Oh,
you don't say oh God bless you.
God bless you.
God Love Ya. God fucking love Ya. Um,
I'm having a great week. Um, we just,
today we did the table read for episode
10, the final episode of season four.
Doctor Dee Dee.
Um, that's it. It's fucking killed. And
I think that we got, uh, coming together.
This was going to look like it's an
even better season than last season. Um,
amazing writers' room this year.
So I mean every year of course,
but this year went to another level,
so thank you to everybody helping out and
all of a sudden the clouds is stat and
a pot and old freckles.
I'm going to have time to aroma size.
You know, I docked out the, um,
all things comedy we're doing,
we're doing some business with the comedy
central, made some standup specials,
and then we have a, a sort of a
premium blend type show that we, uh,
been recording the last two days. It
shooting at I should say. And then a,
tonight's the last night.
Um,
where the fuck is that? I always
forget the name of that Damn Theater.
Let me see here.
It's on seventh AV theater.
Seventh Av,
Los
[inaudible] Los Angeles.
I did a standup show there before
the terragon or something like that.
Is that what it's called? You
fucking asshole bill. Why the
Hell Tara Gone Theater? That's it. The
terragon theater. Um, does that it?
No, that's not it. Hang on a second.
The teragram ballroom,
that's where the show is at tonight.
And I'll be doing like a,
like a half hour after all the young
bucks go up there and they do their thing.
Um, I'm going to close out the
show with a half hour stuff.
Most of it new shit since my last
taping on my special. So, uh,
look at me. I got this special behind
me. I got the, this taping behind me.
I got the fucking,
my s my
efforts for families kind of getting
behind me. I've got to edit it for them,
you know, help edit it for the next, I
don't know how many months, but uh, yeah,
it's all good. So I don't, I don't know
what the fuck I'm going to do with myself.
Maybe get caught up on my reading.
Um, speaking of getting caught up,
how about your Boston Bruins last night?
How'd you like that?
Well, if you didn't, you're from
Montreal or Toronto. Everybody else.
That's what I love about being a Bruins
fan is around the league. People love us.
I've never seen a team when less cups
and have more hatred around the league.
You know what I mean?
You'd think we were actually successful
and so we want one cup since 1972.
Why don't you guys relax? All
right. What do you fucking boots?
Is there anything worse than listening
to somebody complaining about, you know,
physical play,
some of these fucking Toronto fans?
I mean,
I know Bruins fan is probably just as bad,
but of course I don't look at that shit.
You know,
they lose game two and all of a sudden
that they're putting out pictures of like
the refs wearing Bruins
jerseys. It's like, well,
were they wearing Toronto jerseys in the
first fucking game? You assholes. Um,
if we lose the refs cheated pool,
um,
no, it was another, uh,
heart stopping game where we,
I forget what the fuck we were up.
We went up like five, three years.
I thought the game was fucking
over and then all of a sudden they,
they closed it to like, I dunno, four
to three or something like that that my,
my daughter came down. I
missed a little bit of it. I,
I've just been catching it in
patch is a like patches of it.
Um,
even though I'm emotionally all in because
everybody in the house laughed at me
when the Bruins scored. How about
Marshawn sticking with that pass? Huh?
I don't know. I think he gave
it to, I think it was the
to pasta knock first pass.
Went into the Defenseman,
skates a nice play,
and then went right back on his stick
and they gave my day all right there.
Fucking Freddo. Um, loved it.
And the shocker of all shockers,
Tampa Bay losing four straight,
give it up for your Columbus blue jackets
dire right now they're going to have a
long layoff in the big thing they gotta
worry about. It's a let down. I mean, they
gotta be flying. I after beaten this Jay,
but last time I checked, you gotta
Win 16 Games before your host hoists,
Lord Stanley over your head. I'm an old
white guy and I'm talking in Queen Shit.
Cliches.
Can't even say what I'm trying to say.
I want to how long you could
filibuster as a sports announcer.
Just saying all that cliched stuff.
Maybe by going out there,
I played like a team.
Everybody was involved or tell you when
you get all lined fire and good things
are gonna happen.
They went to the net and I'll tell you,
that's where the goals are. Okay? You
can't be out there on the perimeter.
Nobody's ever scored from behind the
goal except for Wayne Gretzky and you're
not Wayne Gretzky.
So I'll tell you why.
Now you've got to get your
fucking Canadian as Russian
ass or whatever the fuck
you are right in front of that Goddamn
now. Cause that's where the goals are.
Yeah, he's God. You have kids say
they're on the wrong side of the puck.
They trying to get on Instagram.
Make it a fucking degree of difficulty.
This isn't high dive. We're not high
dive in here. We're playing hockey.
Yeah.
If I see one more fucking mascot
and one of these Goddamn Marines,
I'm going to throw a kid
down on the ice mark. Oh,
getting a lot of your anger route.
Um,
and I watched a little bit of NBA
basketball or watch some of the, uh,
the Boston Celtics, uh, and you know,
great game there. We fucking
won that game. But uh, I'd
be honest with you, dude,
I don't even know what the fuck goes on
in the NBA anymore. I try to watch it,
but uh, I have a theory on what
happened to the NBA. All right.
Sit down for this one.
If you want to hear somebody who was
picked last in gym class, tell you what,
tell you what's wrong with the NBA.
All right. I'm going big on this one.
I'm going to say it all right.
Michael Jordan,
the greatest basketball player
of all time was also, uh,
one of the worst things that
ever happened to NBA hoop. Okay.
The same way Eddie van Halen in 1978
with van Halen one was one of the worst
things that ever happened to
guitar playing in the 1980s.
All right.
And basically why I'm saying is when you
have somebody of their level of talent,
just an absolute genius,
they are so far beyond everybody else
that when mere mortals interpret what they
do,
they get it wrong because they are limited
by the talent that they were blessed
with.
So with Eddie van Halen,
I know I've used him as a
reference before. So many
people that came after him,
what they looked at Eddie and
they would just like take guitar,
Solo plays many notes as you can within
whatever the four bars that you have.
And then it just became noise.
The whole fucking,
it's some of these fucking guitar Solos.
I mean, I know these guys could play,
but like, you know, it's just like,
it's almost like you ever get cornered
in a party by some fucking coke head and
there's,
there's no back and forth.
There's no conversation that
just fucking punishing you. Yeah.
That's what a lot of those soldiers were.
All right.
And before Michael Jordan came along,
you had to have a big man to,
when you had to feed your big man and
blah, blah, Blah and all that shit.
And he came in with such a talent. He
said, not only do I not need a big man,
I'm going to jump over your big man and
you fucking power forward and I'm going
to sell dominate this game that
the rest of my teammates are.
Their nickname is going to be my
supporting cast nine oh one he started,
you know,
passing the ball and everything.
That's when he started
to beat the Pistons.
I'm not saying he was just
totally doing it himself,
but like all these people
that came after him grew up,
they wanted to be like
Mike and then not Mike,
but there's still play in that way.
So everybody tried to fucking
win and it didn't work.
So the fallout of that, I believe, was
then the pile on championship team,
because Michael set the bar at six
championships in the modern era.
If you wanted to beat Mike or be
as good as him, you had to win six.
And people just weren't good
enough to fucking do it.
So they just had the pile on teams and
it started with Colby and check with the
Lakers, and then you had the big three in
Boston and then the Miami fucking hate.
And now you've got the, uh, the Golden
State Warriors. If you watch it,
I swear to God.
And this,
this fall out of that is you now have
the person that's taken it beyond Jordan
where it's like,
not only do I not need my other teammates,
I don't even like being coached.
So you have somebody out there,
you know, people always, oh dude, he's
got like 21 points in the first half.
It's like,
dude,
the only fucking number that matters
is the score went down by three.
I don't give a fuck east east, this
person is, I just see these guys,
they turn their team into this
one dimensional, an attack.
It's like this guy's going to try to
fucking beat the entire fucking team. Um,
and somehow if you play team basketball,
like the San Antonio Spurs,
nobody pays attention.
And I saw this thing on Instagram showing
all these big stars that have since
retired and they go,
who do you miss the most?
And of course everybody's picking Coby.
I mean, he's probably, I don't know,
I would say he's gotta
be at least the top two,
one on one fucking players of all time.
Absolute beast.
And then you combine that with his wanting
to win and all of that shit. However,
sitting right in the middle and nobody
talking about them was fucking Tim Duncan
. And I might just be an
old fucking asshole here.
But what I liked about Tim Duncan is Tim
Duncan could win with anybody where I
felt like Coby could win,
but he needed everybody.
He needed like a zillion fucking free
agents every fucking year it seemed they
would just every three years they would
clean house and he would get a fresh
batch of some of the best people in
the NBA to play with. Um, I don't know.
So when I watched the fucking game now I,
I'll tell you,
when you got to declare his caliber,
you know,
he's going to have to get his touches.
It's like, dude, fuck his touches.
I was watching the game
last night. Okay. And uh,
what's his face, Reggie Miller.
We go into the fourth quarter.
I think we were up by like two points.
He goes, you know, for the, you know,
the rest of this game is
going to be all Kyrie.
Now maybe he was saying passing the
ball or whatever too. But I dunno,
I just hear that all the time and I've
taught, it makes me feel so old. I'm,
I sit there yelling at the TV like,
Reggie,
you don't believe that you
didn't play that kind of ball.
Even when you were fucking
destroy in the Knicks,
you still knew you had to play team
ball. I know. I don't know. Whatever.
Okay. I'm done with my old man rant.
All right. But I think that that's,
that is basically, like I said, I'm
done and I'm still gonna go here.
I think that that's what's happened with
basketball and for an old guy like me,
that's why I don't get it when I'm
watching it, I'm like, oh my God,
they're down by 10.
And that guy came down,
the court didn't pass it and just launched
a three and throw up a fucking brick.
They're going to call a time out and
put them on the bench and they don't.
It's just how it's played
now. So, but what I will say,
there are things that are
way better. Okay. Before I'm,
I'm that fucking asshole.
You know, giving you the global warming
speech about professional sports. Um,
in no time in basketball,
have there ever been this many people
over the height of six foot 10 that can
hit a fucking three pointer like a guard.
I mean it's, it's fucking unbelievable.
So there are whatever they're
out there are better things. Um,
I will tell you though,
uh,
NHL has changed a lot since I
was a kid and I actually, I like,
I mean I missed the fights. I do miss
two line passes in that type of thing.
But it's, it's a fucking
great game. It's still,
you can't have one guy go out and try to
just take over the entire fucking gay,
by the way.
How about a Vegan knocking
out that fucking 19 year
old can such a weird thing.
He's 33. He outweighed the
kid by fucking 40 pounds.
The kid asked him to fight. What's he
supposed to do? Jesus Christ again,
the old two piece there.
I felt bad for that kid,
but I also respect them having
the balls. You know, 19 years old,
you're playing in the NHL and you
take on a 33 year old Russian. I mean,
you got balls. I got
to give them that. Um,
I don't even know what that
series is at right now, but um,
hang on a second.
Washington Post.
Why the fuck does it say that?
Since when the hell do I look at that?
Maybe I looked at an article.
Washington capitals.
All right.
Why would I want to go to Wikipedia?
Why is that my default fucking thing
every time. Don't enough people.
Not Enough people.
Go to your Goddamn site that you got
to fucking directly right there. Um,
all right. Washington capitals.
The series is two games to one now.
It is fucking wide open.
Wide. Fucking open.
Now the Tampa Bay is, is out of it is
ever bet everybody's eyes fucking lit up.
What a story that would be of the fucking,
yeah.
Columbus blue jackets end up winning
the east. Can you imagine that?
I'm actually enjoying watching them.
Wanting just to see fucking Twitter.
Really smiling. I've never seen
that guy smile so much of my life.
When they went up two games to none,
he was like the smile on his face.
The way he was holding his hands together.
He looked like he was watching his
firstborn take their first few steps.
And as a recovering angry lunatic,
it's fun to see an angry guy
like that show. Just pure joy.
Um,
I feel like in his head it,
he felt like finally I drew up a
game plan that my team heard and they
completely fucking executed it to
a t and it fucking worked. I mean,
that's got to end.
It's gotta be Nirvana for F for a coach.
So that was definitely a
definitely fun to watch.
But I apologize to all the
young people listen to this,
be bitching about the game, but
those are just my theories. Um,
and as you get older, the more theories
you have because it keeps that voice out.
He had, that's guy guy.
You're going to die soon.
Keeps that out of your
fucking head. Um, anyways,
how many minutes have I done here?
How many new meds at the time for the,
the read already?
Fucking penguins lose four straight.
Now is that guy in the front
office? Uh, Josh, Anna Myers,
who's taping is set tonight,
uh,
from the goddamn comedy jam
and the 500 podcast. He's a,
he was telling me that, uh, the capital's
last year, it didn't pay their fee,
their front office guy,
that GM
and all he did was just lead them,
you know,
put together a team that led them to
their first Stanley Cup in the history of
the team and they don't pay him. They
went a little Theo Epstein, dare I say
number that Theo Epstein ended up fucking
86 year curse and they started fucking
with his money. He's like, I'm Outta
here. And then, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Then they paid him. Then a few
years later he was gone. That guy,
he's gotta be the greatest
a front office guy ever.
The guy ended almost a combined 200
years of curses and we wouldn't pay him.
Speaking of which, how about
your Boston Red Sox? My Gut,
all I've been hearing is the stories.
I haven't had time to watch.
Yankees are kicking our ass and
there in fucking last place.
A little bit of a hangover from
the world series party. Once again,
it goes to Wikipedia. Like I don't
know what the Boston Red Sox are.
All right, I know what they are. They're
a fucking last place team right now.
We lose five to three from the new,
from your New York Yankees and that,
that game, I believe we're
six and 13. I wonder,
you know how many fucking assholes at new,
at Yankee Stadium.
We're too busy under the stadium.
Eaton prime rib.
I just have to say as a fucking
baseball fan, that fucking uh,
Roman feast that they have for everybody
down behind home plate. It's just,
it's the fucking worst.
You're the New York Yankees.
You have the most fucking world series
titles. You have the most titles.
Anybody in the four major sports and,
and where are we?
Where are your fucking fence?
Okay.
Down there talking to fucking Rachael Ray.
We have a fucking celebrity chef
is down there cooking for him.
Fucking watching the game to stay
home. Stay home. You [inaudible]
I actually got those seats one
time I went to a game, but I mean,
at least 10 fucking years ago. I forget
how long ago that Steve has been around,
but it feels like it was like 10
years ago, maybe eight years ago.
And I sat down there, I just loaded up,
got my food and got the fuck out there.
And I watched the game and it was
ridiculous. Like the Yankees of course,
probably we're in first place.
And to sit there you felt
like they were like, you know,
already mathematically
eliminated. Um, I dunno,
that's a sad thing. And they said, well,
you know, that's how it is. It's like, no,
it's just greed.
It's greed by the fucking owners
where that capitalism thing, well,
you can't just be a fucking billionaire.
You gotta be a multibillionaire. Yes.
And uh, to the detriment. I don't begrudge
anybody, God knows on my tax rent,
I don't progress as long as
you pay your fucking taxes, um,
but grudge anybody making any more money.
But when it's detrimental to
your product out there right now,
that's when you got to take
a step back and, you know,
try to figure out what matters.
Um,
I dunno, I gotta I gotta fucking, uh,
I guess sit down and watch the game.
I have had a ridiculous urge now that
I have a little bit of time off here.
I mean, I'm going to Iceland during
this toy that goes from Iceland, Israel,
but I really have a,
I have a couple few weeks off in May
before it starts to get crazy again.
And uh, I would love to go
to a fucking Dodger's game.
I think like an old man,
you know,
it fucking keeps score and
have myself a fucking hot dog.
I only wish there was a smoking section
if I could just sit there and smoke
cigars, God dammit. Um,
okay.
In hand with one of my cigar buddies
like Bert Kreischer, you know,
Brits always down to fucking smoke a
stick. Josh, Adam Meyers, you know,
um,
be a hell of a thing or Mike binder
who actually directed my latest special
coming out. And when you guys see
how fucking beautiful this thing is,
you might actually forget this shitty
material you're listening to and that's
what we're going for. All right, let's
do the advertising here. Butcher box,
everybody. Oh, before I forget,
I get to tell you the latest,
cutest thing that my daughter did, right?
The love of my life, the apple of my eye.
Um, I woke her up, right? I didn't
wake her up. She was up. Am I coming?
She's silly as hell and uh,
she's so smart and just keeps
getting more and more beautiful.
And I know I'm bragging is a debt,
but I'm telling you right now,
it's a good looking kid. So, uh,
I get her up and I'm getting a change
and everything. So I said, hey,
I go, you want pancakes for
breakfast? She goes, yeah, I go,
all right. I go, or do
you want a smoothie?
She looks at me and she goes,
pancakes and smoothly.
That's the first time she's used and
she knows to Lincoln or Smoothie as she
says. Um, I just gave her the
pancakes. The healthy wants to,
uh, that I've been making here. All right,
a butcher box, everybody. Here we go. Oh,
I love these guys. Oh, do I love
these guys and you know something.
I'm going to be cooking up some of their,
their heritage bread, pork tomorrow.
I got this, this recipe. I'm
trying, I'm one of those fucking,
you know when you're in line at the
grocery store and they have like a little
magazine that has like a,
just a bunch of recipes.
So this whole issue is dedicated to
just make it an entire meal in like a
skillet, you know, and they
had this great recipe for a,
for a, a, a pork chop dinner. You
know, you sear it on both sides,
up top and then you,
you finish it in the oven with
the heat thermometer did this,
you don't overcook it, dry it out
the fucking thing. Worst thing ever.
It's really involved and there's a
couple of reducing of liquids and putting
pork chops in a, in a, in
a, in a, an aluminum tent.
This is fucking involved and I'm giving
myself permission to only do an okay job
the first time,
but I'm going to get this,
this meal down and this is going to
be one of these meals that when I have
people over, when I'm entertaining,
okay. When I'm wearing one of my, uh,
evening gowns, uh, this is,
this is the meal that I'm going to pull
out to fucking impress people. Of course,
I'll make it. So, um, we,
I'm sorry. We're Vegan now.
It looks delicious if you're into
murdered pigs. Um, all right. Butcher box.
Everybody butcher box delivers healthy
100% grass fed and grass finished beef
free range,
organic chicken and heritage breed pork.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of
antibiotics and hormones before they're
slaughtered. Each box comes with at
least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24
individual size meals.
Or if you're a fat fuck at a Yankee game
that I'd get you to the third inning.
Uh, you can choose from five different
box types, all beef, beef and chicken,
beef. And pork mixed box
custom box. Let you choose,
lets you choose your own
cuts telling you right now.
I don't give a shit if you're
a fucking bulimic vegetarian,
you owe it to yourself. The heritage
breed pork man, I'm telling you,
it's unbelievable. Okay,
the butcher box difference,
but your Brock's meats come from
the humanely raised open pasture.
Animals that are never fed antibiotics,
hormones or fatty fillers.
Get the ultimate breakfast bundle.
That's two packages of Bacon and two
pounds of breakfast sausage for free in
your first box,
plus $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr or
enter the Promo Code [inaudible].
This is great if you've got kids,
this is also good to know that
they're not going to be, you know,
your son won't be able to grow a mustache
by the time he's seven, you know,
keep the hormones out. Keep them
whores outta here. All right,
one more read here. A Helix Helix. Uh,
there's nobody on the planet like you.
You're special.
Everybody needs to hear what
you think on social media.
So why would you buy and generic
mattress built for everyone else?
Um, next please mention all
the talking points below. Well,
if you're fucking wrote it, I'm going to
read it. How long we've been in business.
All right.
Heloc sleep.
He was built a sleep quiz that takes
two minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress.
Whether you're a side sleeper,
a hard sleeper,
like a plush or firm bed.
Oh, behave with helix.
Helicase there's no more guessing
or compromising. Just go to helix,
sleep.com/burr take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for couples.
Helix Helix can even split
the mattress down the middle,
providing individual support needs
and feel preferences for each side.
Let me ask you this. When you
fuck, which side are you on?
I think that depends on
who's on the bottom. Um,
doggy style would be confusing.
Both my knees are on the mattress,
so are mine and my hands. Okay, fair
enough. Honey. Your side of the bed.
All right.
He looks sleep,
was even aware awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019 by Gq
and wired magazine.
And CNN called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on.
They have a 10 year warranty
and you can get to try out.
You get to try it out for
a hundred nights risk free.
Right now a helix helix is offering
up to $125 off their mattress orders.
For our listeners,
get up to $125 off a helix helix,
sleep.com Ma uh,
weight off at Helix.
sleep.com/burr that's helic
sleep.com/bar for $125 off your mattress.
Order Helix,
sleep.com/birth that's h e l I x.
Helux sleep.com/bar.
Um,
oh yeah, I was too. I was telling
you Versie my uh, by the way,
Paul Versey is down in Raleigh,
North Carolina at the Improv this weekend.
And uh, catch him now before he goes
to the theaters. I'm telling you,
I'm telling you, I saw it. I
saw it at that set and God,
he's been absolutely murdering.
But I'll tell you,
it's hard when you're a half Greek,
half Sicilian New Yorker to go down to
Raleigh the first time and headline and
sell some tickets. Uh, go down there and
say that you were there for the first,
his first headlining gig down
there. Um, last I talked to him,
I think he was doing a bunch of radio down
there. So I've been a lot of, you know,
that he's, he's in town. Uh, but I was
talking to him on the phone about, um,
that whole theory that I had on like
basketball because he was laughing,
you know, he always laughs at me
because, you know, he's like the fucking,
and he's a kid to me,
you know,
wearing the Jordans and all that shit
and I'm this fucking old man wearing a
fucking Irish sweater.
Oh, I hate how true that is. And I was
saying like, dude, I swear to God, they,
they treat this stars in this, in the
NBA, they treat them like hot chicks,
you know, I guess they kind of do that in
all leagues, but I dunno, I have no idea.
Bill, please don't go back to
your stupid theories about a game.
You were never really that good
at. You know what? Fair enough.
Fair enough is my impression of
a fucking Laker Fan. Oh yeah.
Of Colby said bad.
How come he also won an Oscar?
Why does he have a fucking Boston
accent? Bill? Let me do that again. MMM.
Oh my God. If like
Kobe's is that bad, like,
you know how many Oscars did
bill Russell when golden globe.
Much.
Yeah.
Then half time yet. I want to get
some botox. I'm sorry. Sorry La.
I love it out here. What am I doing?
Um, all right. Is that the podcast now?
I still got another three
minutes. Um, so anyways,
tonight and we'd be down with that
fucking theater. The ballroom there,
the terragon ballroom a,
is that what it's called?
I gotta look up ballroom.
Is Tara gone like a food?
I Dunno. No, that's Tilapia. That's
a fish. The fuck is terragon.
The Terra Graham is Tara
gonna Spice terragon spice.
Yeah, it is. All right. Okay. I
thought I was going fucking crazy. Oh,
I bet a lot of terror gun's been
putting in bags of weed before. Huh?
I wonder what it's good for.
Tara gone is so good.
If you have tingling in your ass,
just rub a little bit.
All right.
Terragon is a,
is a spices of perennial
herbs in the sunflower family.
I knew I didn't like them. It's a redhead.
You don't like anything about the sun?
Uh,
it is widespread in the wild across
much of your Asia and North America.
America. What is your Asia, is
that Europe infused Asia? Yeah,
and his cult is that the Middle East and
is cultivated for culinary and medical
purposes.
You know the amount of people,
if you ask them what continent
Middle East is in, um,
they would not guess Asia. No,
they would not. And then Turkey,
I believe is half in Europe,
half an Asia. I don't know bill,
but we're all half listening
at this point. Okay.
You're going to fucking shit on the NBA
and then give us what a geography lesson
via a spice. Nobody gives a fuck
about. All right. Fair enough.
Fair enough. Um, all right. Listen,
God bless. All of you. Have a wonderful
weekend. Let's go Bruins. Let's go.
Celtics Red Sox.
It's not too late to turn it around.
I'm sure ESPN is already
having the sky for it. Is it,
is it too early to make a move?
Uh,
it's still snow on top of the
green monster. Um, anyways,
there's going to be a little break here.
Enjoy some music and then they're going
to be another half hour bonus material
of a Thursday afternoon
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a Thursday
earlier this year or from seven years ago.
Whenever the fuck I started doing this.
I'm sorry if this podcast
was a little bit off.
I was icing my calves the entire time.
Um, one of the things, I swear to God,
I didn't realize how fucked
up my God damn body is.
I'm still undoing 40
years. I'm talking, I'm 50.
Yeah,
40 years.
Cause I feel like the first 10 years
it's like a brand new car and you can run
around, do whatever.
Somewhere in like my teens,
I had my first threw out my back and
I'm finally fucking getting this shit
worked out. But uh, Jesus
Christ, dude, I swear to God,
my calves, the lady, she went
to put her fucking elbow in it.
I felt like I literally
had like a softball size,
like ball of Hornets in each of my calves.
Like I was like popping up off the table.
She had to take like this candle thing.
She like,
like I didn't know what the fuck it is.
Like she likes it,
it heats it up and she has to hold it
like a half inch away from the skin to
like melt up,
melt all of the fucking Gristle I've
had from years and years of just,
you know, nobody's stretched
in the 80s you just worked out.
I used to bench do all
the dumb 80 shit right?
And that's how I fucked up my shoulders.
And then I would get on a bike and I
would ride it for like 15 miles every
single day, 18 on Saturday, and then
I would take a day off on Sunday.
We'll your shredded bill.
Yes I was.
I was shredded and a but I never stretched
and now I'm paying the price for it.
Now I look like a fucking bald freckled
Mister Magoo limping around my house.
I literally sit down for like 10
minutes watching TV and when I stand up,
I feel like I've been,
you know that feeling you have when
you've been asleep for eight hours for all
you are the old people out there
of people beginning to feel old.
I've said this before in
the podcast and God damn,
and I'm going to say it again before
you get out of bed in the morning.
All right, take your toes and
pointed back at your knees.
If you immediately feel a Charley Horse,
just point your feet in the opposite
direction and it'll release and you'll be
all right. But pointed met
your needs. If you can,
I'm doing it right now. Oh,
it feels great, right? You
just leave it there for like,
you know, a good 30 seconds,
then go in the other direction.
Point in the other way to get a
Charlie horse that way. Same thing.
Just bring your feet back up
and it'll go away. Hopefully.
But I'm not a professional,
so don't hold me accountable here.
And then once you've
done those two stretches,
move your feet clockwise
and counterclockwise and uh,
and then get up. Don't get up. Cause
what fucks you up is that first step,
that first step of the day when
you haven't stretched and well,
what a way to start, you know, you know,
like, you know when you get out of bed,
you just take that first
step, right? You wake up,
your wife or husband or whatever, you
know, you don't want to do that shit.
All right, that's it. This is
a very old podcasts. You know,
if I keep podcasting like this,
complaining about sports leagues
and my physical ailments,
I think my next big advertiser is going
to be like Geritol did they still make
that shit? They used to always have
that on uh, the Lawrence Welk show.
If you do like these
ads for Geritol Geritol
is that how you spell it? Chevre.
Tall liquids. It's still exists.
What is it for now? The one time I want,
I want fucking Wikipedia to help me out.
I think it's, it's spying on me. All
right, well we're making him mad.
Let it go to Google.
Wiki.
Geritol is United States trademark
name for various dietary supplements,
past and present.
Oh,
see what they did was they
changed with the time and I see,
remember that I'm going to lunch.
Well, good night. Sleep tight
and pleasant dreams to you
is the whitest show ever.
There is a wish and a prayer for every
three become true. I swear to God.
Z on the south end of the show.
Yeah.
And uh,
two we meet [inaudible]
adios.
Or of wealth.
This is them like in a very
like passive aggressive way.
Like shouting out all the people that
we had oppressed. Avi does a night,
we had the, the, the Mexicans in
there, the French and the fucking,
the Germans right there.
What do we do to the French,
French and Indian war right there. I
don't know about near America. There's,
there's a, there's a, this it
America's like Tom Brady were like,
he's beat every team in the league.
I think at this point we've defeated,
we've defeated everybody. You know
I'm cool. Of course I'm kidding.
I'll tell you, you know what?
I'm Manny Pacquiao. Fight
his number. That patio, uh,
uh,
Floyd Mayweather fight.
That should have happened for 10
years and it never did that. That's,
that's the United States and Russia.
I think by the time we get together,
no one's going to give a fuck. That's my
prediction. All right, old fucking bald.
Freckled asshole. Thanks for cheering
me up. Fuck all y'all. I'm sorry.
All right. Enjoy the music
and enjoy the bonus half hour.
Have a great weekend and
I'll see you on Monday.
[inaudible]
hold on. It's built bird. It's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 18th,
2011 fuck.
I almost said it perfectly.
I was so focusing on saying
2011 clearly I fucked up April.
Did you catch that? I say April,
April 18th let me try that again.
Build built our starts his podcast.
Hey to hey, what's going on everybody?
It's built bird is some money.
Morty podcasts for April 18th,
2011 I can't say without slowing down
like some second grader trying to read out
of his book. Greenfield USA.
Did anybody else read that one?
I was talking to somebody the other day.
That's the last geography class I had
in the United States of America was in
second grade. I read a book called
Greenfield USA and I loved it.
They talked about all the
different goddamn states, you know,
they talk about the heartland and
they'd show us a little pictures,
some farmer with the cow holding a bottle
of milk and I remember thinking, Wow,
I wish I lived on a farm and I had a cow.
You know,
my little imagination running wild.
Then they just cut it out and now look,
look at Americans.
You know,
we can't find shit anymore.
Someone was telling me the
other day they found somebody,
they were quizzing these college kids
and kids were putting like Delaware,
like where New Hampshire is.
You know,
that's like that to me that is a
fucking deal breaker. Like if I,
if I was dating a girl, right?
Hottest girl on the Goddamn planet.
And if she thought Delaware was where
was where like New Hampshire was,
you know,
I w I would end that relationship
within eight months because she's hot.
I continue fucking her and then,
uh, hopefully I'd get tired of her,
but in the back of my head it would
just be keeping this bitch doesn't know
where the states are. Well, why,
why would that matter? I mean,
everybody has the talent. Everybody
has their good side and their bad side.
Why did women just defend
every fucking woman out there?
Is it because there's more of you than
there are of us? Is that what it is?
You just gotta be constantly spinning
broad shit in a positive way as you guys
just sit there fucking battling with
each other, Huh? Is that what it is?
I don't know.
Why is my head so fucking itchy this week?
Um, are you supposed to wash your hair
every day? I hear different things.
You're not supposed to, are you? You're
supposed to let your natural oils produce.
Is that what it is? You know, walking
around like some stinky European,
you know, getting off your fucking
awful peewee Herman Bicycle.
What is it with Europe in
those old bicycles? Is He,
because you guys have such
small roads over there,
is that what it is that you guys can't
progress in a bicycle kind of way?
You know?
Is that why we win the Tour de France
every year when we go over there and all
those,
you ever see the bikes that they ride?
Even like the bikes that they
ride in the Tour de France,
the Italian bikes are terrible,
horrible bikes.
Just trying to get them going just in
case I have any Italian fucking listeners
over there. Bellissimo
Mangia Mangia you know, bad.
I want to fucking go to Italy
and just gained 900 pounds.
Evidently you don't because they haven't
fucked with their food over there.
I've been reading more and more about
food. Basically what we eat over is,
is it the closest thing to straight up
poison? I don't even think we're fat,
lazy fucks. I just think
they're poisoning us. Um,
like I guess the Pasta over there
in Italy is like, I don't know.
It doesn't gluten free.
Whatever the fuck that means.
I don't know what glutenous but
evidently you don't want a lot of it.
Your Pasta and their shit over there.
It's gluten free.
I don't mean,
I don't know if that means there's no
gluten over there or the gluten they have
is not oppressed like it is in this
country. I don't know what it is,
but all I know is those motherfuckers
over there, you know, they just sit there,
this eat spaghetti all day.
They have conversations with the shit
hanging out of their mouth. You know,
using that tie is a napkin
and everybody has a Ferrari.
Isn't that what it is?
You guys know what I did this week?
You know what I did this fucking week?
I actually went down and I finally
decided I'm getting a second car.
I decided, fuck it. I'm telling you,
that shit over there in Japan
really fucked with me. You know,
considering I live on a fault line,
all right,
I realize I need to live for today and
I also realize I need to be prepared in
case some of that shit went down.
So my first step in secure in my perimeter
is all of them. Good old boys do down
the south. Everybody makes fun of them.
Hey, we're all just fucking
stupid rednecks, right?
Those rednecks are the
smartest motherfuckers on
the planet as far as they are
ready for. When the shit goes
down, they're ready. All right?
They got trucks, they got guns.
They know how to kill Shit. Skin it,
gut it, cook it, eat it, fuck it.
They know how to do all of that.
Laid out a head for the hills,
man, they know how to do that.
They live in the middle
of fucking nowhere.
The great thing about living in the middle
of fucking nowhere is you don't have
that many games on your schedule. You know
what I mean? You live in the city. Okay?
You got a full schedule of potential
zombies and whatever coming over the
fucking Goddamn rail trying to run up
the stairs to your apartment. Okay?
I don't care how many
fucking bullets you got.
You're going to run out and
eventually they're going to overrun.
Yet they're going to take your shit and
fucking have sex with your dead body.
Jesus bill. Really? Yeah. Really? That's
how it goes down in the apocalypse.
Those rednecks,
they live in the middle of nowhere.
They got a big field
all around their house.
They got like 12 kids so they can
all look out every fucking window.
Who's kidding?
Who?
They can put four kids for their three
windows right in each window on all sides
of their little fucking outhouse, and
there's no way to sneak up on them. Yeah,
you got to crawl on your fucking elbows.
You're not going to do it.
You're going to leave him alone. They
live in the middle of fucking nowhere.
But when you live in the city,
that's when you got to get worried.
You know, unless you're lucky
enough to live in a gated community,
gated community. You know, why did
I say that? Pick up the papers.
Pick up the papers. You know,
the gated community, you know,
either you're so famous or you've stolen
so much from regular people that you
feel the need to live behind
a fucking wall. You know?
Have you guys noticed that on Google
maps that when you try to take the little
guy and bring him down into
a gated community, they
won't let it do it? You know?
Why are they so fucking special?
What did they do?
You know,
have you guys do me a favor? Can,
can you guys, my listeners now,
you should not do this.
You shouldn't do this.
I'm not advocating doing
this. Wink, wink. But, uh,
why don't you sprays,
paint something on the wall outside of
gated community that just makes those
people not feel so God damn comfortable.
You know,
I'm sick of them being Cousey smug counts.
Just sitting in there thinking
everything's going to be all right.
Just do something.
Don't do anything to any of them.
Just spray paint something crazy
like, hey fuckers, your next.
MMM,
where's the bailout?
I Dunno what the fuck.
Just write something that's vague
that kind of includes all of them.
So they don't know who's a target just
so they're a little bit nervous when
they're in there eating their gluten
free pasta that they have flown in,
you know?
Oh, so anyways, so you know what I
did? I went down to this, oh Jesus.
What the fuck did I just do?
Oh,
I thought I just hit that you were at
they raised button. No. So anyways,
so I went down to this,
this place where they specialize in old
mustangs and I went down there and I was
going to a, I was going to
order one and just say fuck it.
This is the year I want,
this is what I want on it.
Tell me how much it fucking costs and
I'm going to book some road gigs and uh,
do the level of Catholic guilt,
even though I don't even fucking,
I don't even believe in that shit anymore.
I don't believe in it.
Okay.
I Dunno if you go somewhere when
you die or any of that type of shit,
but I know all his fucking religious
stuff. Other than the basics,
the 10 commanded switch, you know, you
really could have made one commandment.
Just don't be a cunt, right? Isn't
that what it's all about? Tapia can't.
Don't take the Lord's name in vain.
Don't disrespect your parents.
Don't steal my shit. Don't fuck my
wife. Don't want to fuck my wife.
Don't be a content. What's wrong with you?
Hey, look at me. Yeah, you, you're a cunt.
Cut it out. That basically sums
up the foundation of every,
every religion and then
it turns into guys,
right? Buddha. I like Buddha.
That's a good one. You know,
some happy fat fuck just
sitting there all jolly.
Can't even see his dick and
he's still happy. You know,
there's something empowering
about that. Jesus. I'm not
into, you know, I, you know,
and it's not even his fucking pot smoking,
you
know, Goddamn hackey sack of
vibe that he's putting out.
You know,
his God damn
rope made out of Ganja. It's
not even that. It's, it's a,
I hate the fucking martyr
aspect of my religion. You know,
I did it for you. I hate
that shit. You know,
somebody slaps you in the face, you
turn the other cheek, do it again.
Will that make you feel better?
Yeah,
the meek shall inherit the earth.
It's just,
it's just a blueprint for being a pussy,
you know,
fucking can't stand it.
And that is Jewish religion.
I don't know shit about it.
I just know when you get really into it,
you got to grow those curly Q Elvis side
burns and then you got
to wear that little, uh,
that little round thing on the
back of your head, you know,
and then wear the same shirt at the
same pants every fucking day or the same
style.
You know,
what are you fucking Albert Einstein or
you over there working on theories of
relativity. You're not, you're not.
Alright, go get yourself an izod shirt.
I had a little fucking color
to your wardrobe. Can you,
can you fucking have a little bit of fun?
Um,
what else?
Yeah.
Oh,
then the Muslim religion.
I don't want to get down on my knees
every day at four in the after I'm fucking
old. My knees hurt. I
don't want to do that shit.
I got to carry a yoga mat
around everywhere. I fucking
go and try and figure out,
you know, which way is South East
or whatever the hell hubspot I had,
I want to do this. I don't
wanna fucking do any of that. So
I think that's pretty much co Scientology.
That's the last one.
You know,
that one I would actually join because
it's just something funny about it,
you know, being a fly on the wall, hanging
out with that level of Weirdo. You know,
I think they're the weirdest.
I'd have all of them sign
ontologist just because
the fucking religion,
like all other religions were started.
They'd seems way the fuck back in the day.
So there's this vagueness that there's
no proof that it's complete bullshit,
you know?
But l Ron Hubbard has a quote,
if you want to make you want to become
a millionaire, start a religion.
He basically admits that he
kinda just made all this shit up,
said that he was the guy.
He did it in like the forties you know,
and they're all sitting
around there waiting for a
fucking spaceship to show up.
I just want to go down there and have a
really fucking intense conversation with
Tom Cruise, you know, and just
see if I can get them going.
You know
what I would do is I would just say that
was a little confused about a certain
aspect of my life, just to watch him go
into fucking motivational speaker mode.
You know, laughing maniacally,
you know, Scientology,
they got in all religions,
they have those giant cavernous buildings.
So when somebody laughs Menai maniacally,
you get that,
the fucking amazing acoustics,
you know,
I'll the same acoustic set or like a
Jimmy page's stairwell when they recorded
the drums for when the levee breaks,
you know, good. Those drums sound.
Just imagine somebody laughing
in that fucking stairwell,
you know what, should I add some reverb
here and give you a maniacal laugh?
That'd be too much fucking work. Um,
anyways, so this is what I did, the suit.
So I went down there to go a fucking,
see if I could get a Mustang and the
place was closed and then I'm driving back
and I'm like, what's that a sign? Was
that a sign that I shouldn't have done it?
And it's like, no, Bill, that's
a sign that you're a dumb fuck.
And he didn't check to see what
their hours were, so whatever,
whatever. So this is what
I did this week. All right.
I did a lot of shit this week,
by the way. Let me, let me,
let me remember before I tell
you that fucking story. Uh,
I did Kevin James
podcast this week and uh,
that is gonna be, I say
Kevin James. Kevin Smith.
I did Kevin.
Oh,
JJ.
That's going to be one of
these fucking weeks, isn't it?
I did Kevin Smith's podcast. It's
going to be uploaded today. Um,
he does actually. He did. He
didn't show up. He was sick.
So I actually sat in for him, which was
really nerve wracking because I, you know,
mommy where like what?
Like the ice capades when I saw him
in 1976 at the old Boston Garden,
I saw him in the late seventies.
Actually,
Dorothy Hamill didn't show up and we
were all fucking upset and they had some
other chick,
a substitute and everybody fucking boots.
So I was worried that these, these
comic book Reading Psi Phi Fans,
we're gonna boo me and
they didn't. Um, and uh,
fortunately, uh, Ralph Garman,
his cohost fucking hilarious.
He made me feel totally comfortable.
I did the show with him and that, um,
that podcast is going to be up today.
All right. See you getting to two
podcasts from me today. All right.
You're probably going to be
completely second, ma'am.
I am getting over exposed in the podcast
world. I did Doug Benson's last week.
I did,
I did Kevin Smith's on Saturday EHRs
today and on Wednesday I'm going to do the
Sklar brothers.
I'm making the podcast rounds people.
I think I am becoming a fucking
goto guest and the podcasting world.
You know, like back in the day
when somebody canceled all fuck,
we need a guest back in the day and the
tonight show who they go with. They, they,
they bring in George Gobel,
they bring in Burt Reynolds.
Dude, that fucking
cannonball run laugh, right?
That's what are becoming
in the podcast world.
I did Joe Rogan's like
fucking three weeks ago.
Who else am I doing? I think I'm
doing Chris Porter's coming up.
Ah,
you know,
I am just doing all kinds of free work
here in the podcasting world. People,
that's what it's all about.
Speaking of which,
speaking of which,
um,
I actually on the MM podcast
page for the first time ever,
we have installed a donation button.
So if you want to stop listening to me
cry like a cunt, if you'd like, you know,
whatever. If you want to donate to the
podcast, I'd really appreciate it. Uh,
cause this is a ton of work.
I do appreciate the fact that I do get
to communicate to you guys, but you know,
if you want to fucking
donate or whatever works,
we're starting to take this
thing to the next level.
I came up with the new
Monday morning podcast logo,
or actually at the real thing
is I paid somebody to do it.
We got tee shirts and shit like that.
We got some merchandise coming. So,
uh, so that way the podcast can continue
to be free. If you want to donate a buck,
whatever you want to donate, five
bucks, fucking six bucks, three 50,
whatever the fuck you want to donate.
If you go to Yemen podcast page, mm,
podcast.com it's on the right hand
side, just under the, uh, Twitter,
Facebook buttons you'll see
donate. Just click on there, uh,
and go right through paypal, whatever. All
right. Donation. Only just like a church.
Can I guilt you guys?
How can I get you like Jesus?
And he said it under you with
go fuck with yourself. Um,
and what else? I really gotta
get this shit out of the way.
I have to make sure that I do treat my
career like a business at some point here,
so I do have to hire a couple of
things here. All right. Uh, my pop,
my web guy said, remind everyone to
follow you on Twitter. He made a list,
a list here because I blow
this every week. All right.
Follow me on Twitter at Bill Burr.
Uh, I believe that's my Twitter. Now.
You know my fucking Twitter name. It's
either add bill burr@billboard.com.
I think it's just at Bill
Burr B. U. R. R. A. I tweet,
I talk about things I Twitter, I
don't tweet. That's the masculine way.
Let's see. Homophobic way of
tweeting you Twitter. What else?
Who also feel also tell them to feel free
to hit the share button when you post
videos on your Facebook page. Oh yeah.
I'm trying to get my Facebook page,
the fan page,
trying to get those numbers up.
Revet at 2,500 people since Tuesday.
We're trying to keep that thing going.
You know what people, I'm actually,
for the first time in my career,
I'm going to try to use the
Internet to my advantage. See,
up until this point, I really
had no game plan. It was like,
I'm just going to go on here.
I'm going to say a bunch of
stupid shit for a fucking hour.
And you know, if people like it, they
fucking like it man. And if they find it,
they fucking find it. And I
realized that, you know what,
there's nine zillion podcasts
out there. I need to, I gotta
advertise. I got to fucking,
I got to do what the fuck I gotta do here.
I'm finally realizing that, you know,
turn in 43 in Jude.
You know,
at some point I would like to,
uh,
feel that if,
you know,
I don't know what if I
was to lose my pancreas,
I could still have a enough money
squirreled away that I could,
I could afford oatmeal for
breakfast for the rest of my life.
Isn't that what everybody wants?
Don't you guys have,
don't you have a number in your fucking
head? What's your number? You know,
if you guys watch breaking bad,
you guys watch that fucking show.
Do you know uh Eisenberg is Mr. White?
His,
his big numbers 600 grant.
You can get 600 grand in cash squirreled
away into the bottom of his house.
If he kicks the bucket, his
family's going to be okay. See,
so I don't have a family. I got my
girl. All right. And I got my dog.
All right.
But I plan on fucking living and I don't
have a terminal disease like Mr. White.
Actually he's in remission on that show.
Sorry I'm getting a little
fucking breaking bed.
I'm going a little geek here
for that show. Um, excuse me.
What would be my, I have no fucking
idea where my finger would be.
Definitely six.
You need six figures,
right? What'd you guys do that? You know,
cause everybody wants a fucking house.
It's easy. Here's something
for you. Everybody wants a
house. All right. Oh wait,
let me explain that shit real quick
cause I don't even think I explained it.
I May, I may Facebook page, the fan
page. We're going to start posting.
Some are some of the funny videos,
the youtube ones and if you like them only
feel like, if you think they're funny,
just share them with the rest of your
friends and then hopefully they'll see
that and they'll be like, well, who
the fuck is this redheaded character?
And then they'll go onto my
page and if they like my comedy,
then they fucking add me,
you know?
And then maybe I can catch up
with some of the of these other
comedians out there who are playing these
gigantic venues with,
with uh,
with fucking sparklers set come down at
the end of their shows. Right. People,
I want to sell out everybody that
there's an assignment for you this week.
Come up with a catchphrase for me.
What is something that I can see?
What
can I die? No Matte. What can
I say at the end of my jokes?
Huh? Maybe I can just do that path at the
everywhere with, would that be enough?
And then I sell, Huh? T shirts at the end.
Is that what I gotta do you know
what this really is? People.
I know what you're thinking is,
is bill just going to give up all
fucking integrity in order to, this is,
I need a fucking vacation.
It's coming up in June
1st two weeks of June.
I'm on vacation and I know what you
think and you're going to still do the
podcast, man, of course I'm gonna.
I'm not gonna leave you hanging.
I'm fucking, I'm gonna. I want
to go to the middle of nowhere.
I want to get a cabin.
That's what I want to do. Are
there any rednecks, listen to this shit
anyway. Can you recommend me some shit?
Who's going to be the first podcast
listener to take me hunting?
All right, and you got to know, I
don't know how to shoot anything,
but I will fucking shoot something.
I don't have a problem killing an animal.
I don't. If I'm out there, it, they'll,
they'll be enough mosquitoes that
I'll be in enough of an ornery mood.
You know,
I already told you I could shoot a
fucking deer as long as it didn't have any
dear friends standing around or any
little kids, doe's whatever it is.
You know,
I was kidding.
Who if it was a really majestic
looking one with a bunch of fucking,
what do they call it? A 12 pointer or
something. I couldn't shoot that either.
We just, it had to be a stupid
looking deer just standing.
They have fucking just,
you know, you could just tell
a bear's going to club it
over the head soon, right?
Isn't that how bears kill their fucking,
their prey and they
like picked up a stick.
They start bashing it over the fucking
head, like Hannibal Lecter. Um, anyways,
that he finished hype and everything.
Uh, I think that's it. Oh,
and this week I'm also going to be at the
PABST theater in Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
Um, there's only a little as only a few
tickets left for that one and the Detroit
show is sold out.
So I want to thank both those blue collar
towns that I'm finally making my way
to. I got there without having to
have a puppet or a catchphrase.
People very proud of that.
But now I want to play,
I wanna play Tiger Stadium.
So I need,
I need a catch phrase.
Everybody come on.
Okay.
And I'll try him out too.
I'm not beyond it.
I will try them out next
week on the podcast.
Come up with a fucking horrific one.
MMM.
Oh wait a minute.
Didn't what's his face already do this
Ricky Gervais based and he'd do that.
Did he do his show? He used to
watch that show. He was an extra,
are you having a laugh?
That's such a great fucking,
that's the perfect,
that's just,
that's brilliant writing
right there that they,
I don't know if Ricky Gervais' came up,
but I don't know who came up with that,
but that is just so fucking, that
is, that's just perfect Gad. Damn.
That's just where might even funny. Right
now. I'm just sitting here just fucking,
not just, you know, you don't
wanna do it right now. I am.
I'm sitting right now on my bed,
legs sideways on my bed, uh,
laying on my side with my head in my head.
You know,
like I'm posing for playgirl
magazine, you know, like the,
the Burt Reynolds pose back in the 70s.
Look at me, I think. I think I'm getting,
I think I'm getting a fucking ego.
Got An extra 2,500 friends
on my Facebook page.
I'm telling people to follow
me on Twitter. Look at me.
I'm not even being funny this
week. I'm just hyping shit and a,
we got to the New Lady,
Bill Byrd Tank tops coming out.
I can't fucking do this shit. All
right, let's plow ahead here. Uh,
let's get into the podcast,
shall we?
MMM.
I have so much shit to talk. I'm very
25 fucking minutes into this thing. Uh,
let's try to blow through this quickly.
My parents came to town this week,
this weekend, came out here to
visit. And uh, you know the deal.
You feel like you're an adult. You feel
like you're a man. You're a guy's guy.
You're driving down the street.
Yeah.
Hybrid with your fucking arm hanging
out the window and you made sure you put
sunblock on so he didn't get cancer
because you're a fucking fat,
right?
You think he got the world figured out,
then all of a sudden your parents show
up and immediately you turn into a kid
again, you, you want their
approval. So, you know,
I don't have any kids.
I don't have anything to show that I am
living for anybody other than myself.
I am living a selfish artist's life.
I play guitar,
I play drums, I play hockey.
I fucking tell jokes,
fuck it,
do whatever the hell I want to do.
I just sit around all day
staring at my both. It's great.
It's fucking great. I don't know
why the fuck you guys ever, I know.
I get shows love.
I don't know why you ever gotten married.
I don't know why you ever had kids and
then you fucking change yourself to your
cubicle.
I don't know why you did it,
but evidently it's worth it because
everybody I know has kids goes [inaudible]
yeah.
I pluck a workout day and every morning
my boss comes in and slaps me in the
face with his tie and calls me a
bitch. And I say, thank you sir.
May I have another? Am I fucking hate
my job? Or I tell you when I get home,
when I get, Oh, and I just
see my kid. Yes. Vag. Yeah,
whatever they say all they fucking
horse shit. And the thing is,
is I know it's true. I know it's
true. I know when I have a kid,
I'm not going to give a
fuck how I look anymore.
You know I'm not going to moisturize.
I want to be walking around in old
clothes and old fucking gym shoes.
That's my biggest fear. If I ever become
a parent, I'll just become a parent,
you know, and just dress like shit and
drive that old car. I don't want to do it.
Why? Why? If you become a parent,
why Jerry Seinfeld has Porsches,
what am I talking about?
See there's a smart fucking guy, you
know, we made his dream come true.
He made his half a fucking billion.
He got a fleet of Porsche's and
then he went down to the gym.
He picked out some check. I don't give
a fuck if you fucking engaged. Let's go,
sweetie. I got half a billion
dollars. Come over here,
come over here and ride my rich cock,
right?
Then he starts pumping out the fucking
kids. Late forties early fifties people.
That's if you're in your early
twenties that's how you do it.
That's how you do it.
You make your million first.
Then you grabbed some
bitch by her fucking here.
You drag her up the stairs and you say,
listen woman,
I know you want shiny shit.
I can buy you shiny shit.
All right,
so make a decision.
Go ahead and choose love. You fall in
and out of it during the relationship.
You know it's gonna wear off
and that way you're going to be,
you're going to be sitting
there and some fucking house.
I'm drab ass fucking house.
Cheerio's in your hair.
Bunch of little ones running
around. And then what? Oh,
you could choose me shiny shit.
You want a nice shiny kitchen counter
with the shiny fridge. You know,
I'm 50 years old.
I've been working for 35 fucking years.
I have no dependents.
I can buy you the shiny shit you want.
So why don't you come over here and
ride my half a century old cock.
Yeah.
You know,
take my fucking dusty seaman,
fertilize you, and then we'll have
a couple of fucking kids you know,
and you can be the one who plays with
them and I'll just sit here and a fucking
old sweater rocking back and forth
going, I did it. I did it. Eaten pot,
cookies, whatever the fuck I
want to do. I don't give a shit.
I have enough money for help.
That's my game plan.
People as I sit here in
a one bedroom apartment,
my early forties and sweatpants
and a fucking tee shirt,
I'm still holding on to that dream people.
Anyways,
the fuck was so my parents come to town.
That's what the fuck
I'm trying to tell them.
It's what it's what really try to talk
about here. If my parents come to town.
Yeah. And uh, so I don't have any kids.
I don't have anything to show him.
I'm driving a fucking hybrid. Nothing I'm
doing is really that impressive. So, uh,
what do I do?
I just start taking them out to,
you know that that was the only card I
had the play. Look at all the cool places.
I know where to go.
That's all I have people,
you double my age.
I'm 84,
42 years of living on this planet.
That's all I can show.
My parents is places to eat.
So I've been actually been doing
really good with the hiking,
taking my fucking awesome dog for hikes.
And then I come home and I have a big
bowl of fucking oatmeal, you know,
and I have it the real way. I just
have oatmeal like of prisoner of war.
Just swap it right in the bowl,
throw a little bit of raisins on it.
That's the only fucking excitement
I allow during my breakfast moment.
You know, all you fucks out there
trying to lose weight. What do you do?
You make something healthy and then you
fucking had your drugs to it, don't ya?
You sugars, salts, put a little milk in.
There would have been a
little cinnamon sugar. How,
but I put a scoop ice cream on top of it.
What'd you have for breakfast?
I had oatmeal. I'm telling you
it's my metabolism. No, it isn't.
You cheat and fuck. Stop putting up
the, the, the food steroids, India.
Healthy food.
You got to sit there and yet,
you know what you gotta do is
you got to get that fucking,
you gotta get that, uh, that desire,
that craving out of your body.
You know, like you guys do. If you watch
my standup specials, you
guys realize that, uh,
I have a sweet tooth. I hate that about
myself. Eh, but you know what it was?
I fucking just stopped eating
them and it took about a week.
Every night he'd be driving home going,
I want a piece of cake. What the fuck is,
what is your, your, your birthday
bill. The fuck's wrong with me.
I want a piece of cake or like a pint
of ice cream. I just wanted it. Right.
But then after a fucking week, your body
just gets that craving audio system.
Now I don't want it anymore.
And you know what's funny is
now that it's out of my system,
I walked into this place the other day
and they had to go in and get this,
this three bean salad. You
know, cause I'm really,
I'm trying to get the booze weight off,
you know,
cause I quit Busan but I just kept
eating like an idiot. I'm trying to make,
get my head back down to the
size it should be. Right.
So I'm going in the order that,
and I'm sitting there of course right
in the front, they get like, you know,
seven different kinds of
cakes and all this shit.
And because I wasn't craving sugar
like it looked, it looked bizarre.
It looks like clown food, all these
bright colors and shit. Like why the fuck?
Why would you even eat that shit? Um,
you know, the week before or find it.
And it had some,
some bad food.
I would have fucking bad my face
pressed up against the glass trying to,
you know, just one, eat
half the cake, so whatever.
So I've been doing great with,
with my,
my date and all that type of shit
that my parents come to town. And uh,
that's all I had. I was just like, I,
you know, I just started taking them out.
I fucking had, you know,
a couple of cheeseburgers.
I was eating a fucking
grand slam breakfast last
night at some fifties diner.
Took him out to some French restaurant,
eaten beef Borgen y'all
the Stewpot that looks like the
jolly green giant made the shit.
And uh, I'm at that age a
couple of days, eaten bad again,
like five fucking pounds. Now I've
got a big doughy white stomach again.
It's killing me. So anyways, this is
how fucking hilarious my parents are.
They come out to visit me in Hollywood.
All right.
Where do you think they want it to go?
What? Tourist attraction. Go ahead,
I'll give you a second to guess.
What are you going to guest to go
look at the Hollywood walk of fame?
All those stars on the sidewalk,
Mann's Chinese theater,
Hollywood bowl, sunset strip. Go down
and look at the paramount studios.
Get their picture taken in
front of the Hollywood sign.
Now you know what they want it to go.
They wanted to go to the
Ronald Reagan library,
the Ronald Reagan Presidential Library.
How fucking awesome is that?
You know,
you know the deal on it.
Whenever you live in a city for awhile,
if you live in Saint Louis,
every time you come there,
what are people want to go to? The
fucking arch. You don't want to go there.
You don't give a fuck.
They want to ride that little
stupid elevator up to the top.
You don't want to do it, but you
gotta do it. You live in New York.
Douchebag wants to go
to the top of the empire state building.
You don't want to do it.
So my parents came out here
and I'm thinking, Oh God,
I gotta take him to the usual spots.
And they said that they wanted to go to
the Ronald Reagan Presidential Library.
And I was like, that. That's in Hollywood.
They're like, no, no, no.
It's, uh, out west west of, uh,
la. And I was like, you know
what? I'll fucking do that.
I'll do that in a second. And I went out
to him and I had a great God damn time.
Uh, that's something you ought to do.
You gotta go to a presidential library.
It's fucking hilarious.
Especially if it's a president where
you were alive when all the shit that
happened went down.
So then you can go into their library
because the libraries are hilarious.
I don't give a fuck who it is.
They are going to make that guy look,
this is like the third library.
I bet at the JFK.
I've been to the Richard Nixon
and I've been to the, uh,
now the Ronald Reagan.
None of these
where my ideas, I'm a, I'm a fucking
moron. I don't want to go to these things.
I've just always with people
who want to go to this shit.
And what I've noticed with the libraries
is they just make the person seemed
just like the greatest
fucking person ever. Like,
evidently Ronald Reagan
was the greatest guy ever,
which amazes me because I
thought it was Richard Nixon.
And before that I thought it was
fucking JFK. They just, uh, you know,
they had one part of it. They
had this whole, you know,
that whole just say no to drugs thing
that they came up with was a miserable
failure. I remember it. I remember
that people used to make yes, well
just say no. Okay, well that
solves the crack epidemic.
When somebody asks you for
drugs, just say no. Okay.
Meanwhile,
we're going to cut funding for anything
that would help you get out of your
financial fucking problem
in the inner city. You know,
and then the one viable commodity,
the drugs which you either sell and make
money or you take to fucking numb the
pain of living in a goddamn war zone.
Just say no to that.
Just just say you don't want to do it.
And then continue going
to an incredibly unsafe,
shitty school that we're not going to
help to try to make anything better.
So they, but in the library, it was
just an absolute smashing success.
And they was showing her just say no
and her hugging some inner city children
and the dress she wore,
this is just the Nancy Reagan part
and that they actually, you know,
was the best part. They had an,
they had to just say no board game,
which I was trying to take a picture of,
but the fucking security
kept looking at me.
You weren't allowed to take pictures and
the Ronald Reagan Presidential Library.
And I just wanted to see like,
you know,
I just wanna I wanna I gotta
look that up on the Internet.
I want to know what happens.
How do you lose that game?
Do you like slowly become a junkie as
you play that game? Are they like know
if the end of the board game
is there one gated community,
nice neighborhood where you live with
all the banker costs and then there's
another one where you make the left
turn and you just send some fucking slum
that they cut funding to.
Is that basically yet? Um,
so having gone to that and then the, the
Reagan thing was just like, you know,
obviously I like to Shitty did where
he strengthened our military, you know,
and then the Russians tried to
strengthen their mallets military,
then they fucking went bankrupt.
That was a great fucking move.
Ended up being the worst
thing for this country though.
I think because you need an adversary,
you need one.
Cause if you don't,
then you just become a greedy cont cause
there's nobody stopping you from just
fucking eating every piece of cake
that's on the goddamn table. But anyways,
so I haven't gone to the Reagan won.
I now want to go to the Bill Clinton one
because I want to see how they spin all
that. Monica Lewinsky. I finger fuck
some fat whore in the White House.
I just got to see, cause they gotta
address it cause he got impeached.
He's only, only two presidents in
history have ever gotten impeached.
It's him and some other fucking guy.
I forget the other guy.
Everybody thinks it's fucking Nixon.
But he did.
Nixon resigned before that shit happened.
He pulled a Manny Ramirez.
I'm going to Spain, I'm out. See Ya. Um,
but,
uh,
I dunno man.
It was really,
it was as much as I'm making fun
of Reagan and that type of Shit.
Like, you know, I don't buy
into Democrats or Republicans,
they all serve the same fucking guys.
It doesn't make a difference,
especially at this point. But it was
just interesting to see. Uh, I'd like, I,
I'm still into the memorabilia,
like the creepiest part of the Reagan
library is you fucking go through it.
And remember when John Hinckley
tried to kill him, they,
you walk into this one part,
they go,
this is the assassination part of
the Ronald Reagan fucking library.
And you walk in there and there's three
screens all showing the exact same thing.
And they go,
it'll start in 10 seconds.
And they just show the raw
footage of Reagan walking out.
And this guy squeezing up
six fucking shots. You know,
Brady got shot in the head. Thank God
it was a 22 or is he would've been dead.
But, uh, uh,
a DC police officer and the secret
service officer all got shot.
And then Reagan took one that
ricocheted off the car and caught him.
So it's just the raw footage.
There's no like, uh, you know, like
fucking Tom Brokaw go on tonight.
Nightly News. [inaudible] good.
What'd your checking to be?
Sure there wasn't any of that.
They just showed it like you was standing
there was the creepiest shit ever.
Just these walking out waving and
then pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
And then everybody just died.
[inaudible]
the car fucking drives away
and you're like, Jesus Christ.
So then you walk into the next room,
which is like 10 feet away
and there's no door. Okay.
And now you're looking at the suit that
Reagan wore when he got shot and there's
a bullet hole right in the fucking,
the coat decided the
coat and then you know,
the fucking assassination,
the attempt,
the raw footage is
playing every 10 seconds.
So now you're looking at the suit and
then all of a sudden you just hear pop,
pop, pop, pop [inaudible]
here. And it just kept playing.
[inaudible] it just was like,
dude, what the fuck? And I,
that was the only part of the library
I didn't like. It's like a gut.
Jesus Christ and I had to leave,
but the best part of the library,
and I got pictures of this up on the MLM
podcast.com is they fucking had a air
force one,
a seven 57 the entire fucking plane.
They had it in case within the building
and you could go and you could go on the
fucking thing and they had the place
where the guys set with the, you know,
the nuclear devices turn your key.
This is what blew my mind too when
you got on the plane is, you know,
now we're just starting to
get the technology where
US regular people can be on
the Internet and use phones and shit.
They had that technology on Air Force
One back in the day when fucking Reagan,
Carter,
all those guys you could,
you could pick up a rotary
phone and call the Kremlin,
whoever the fuck you needed to
talk to on a goddamn rotary phone.
So that means that their technology is
at least 35 years ahead of us that, that,
that would be the only reason why
I would ever want to be president.
I just want to see what,
like Obama's cell phone looks like,
the capabilities of it, you know, anybody
was any of that fucking interesting.
Um, all right, let's, let's move on here.
Uh, real quick and then we'll start.
I'm going to get into the whole
fucking, ah, questions for the week. Uh,
oh.
Coming up this next week, Tribeca
Film Festival starts and, uh, me,
Robert Kelly and Joe de Rosa
have a movie that got selected,
a short film called cheat. And somebody
sent me an email about it. It said, uh,
hey bill, how you doing? So Dude, just
watch the trailer for cheap and man,
I got to tell you, it looks quite
good. It's really cool to see you,
Bobby and Joe and even dumb fos
doing something serious like this.
Is it going to make it,
yeah.
Run across theaters.
Uh,
what are the chances of it being on
DVD sometime? Uh, this is the deal.
It's just short film. So, uh,
we'll probably try and put it
in other film festivals, but,
um,
we're currently
are writing a book, me,
Joe and Bobby and uh,
that's based off of the movie and
the book will be out next year,
beginning part of next year hopefully.
And in the back of the book, um, the, the,
the full movie will be
available. So the, the,
the movie itself cheat will
come with the book and a,
I can't tell you what it's about because
I don't want to ruin the fucking movie.
So I'm glad you think that it looks cool.
And, uh, anybody in the New York area,
please go onto the Tribeca
that I don't have.
Of course, as always, I don't have any
information. I'll have it next week,
next week. By the way, a,
I'm going to Bobby and Joe de Rosa
on my podcast the first time ever at,
there's going to be three people on my
podcast, a two guests at the same time.
I'll see how I handled that. I went
out and I bought a third mic. People,
I'm ready to do it. So, uh, what else?
What else did I want to talk about?
Um, oh, how about the Bruins? Huh?
How about the Bruins? Digging themselves
a fucking hole. I still have faith.
I got to feel, and the Bruins are
going to go into Montreal tonight.
They're going to kick the shit out of
those fake fucking Parisian motherfuckers
up there. Um, you know what's annoying me?
It's not even knowing me that we're
losing to the Canadians, cause I know.
I don't know why people were picking
the Bruins to win the cup. I just was,
was still missing at least two major
pieces to have a championship run.
But what's killing me is they're making
Carey price look like he's Ken Dryden.
Any isn't. He isn't. These are
the first two playoff games.
This guy is ever fucking one and
his entire career. All right.
The last time we saw
this guy in the playoffs,
we beat them four games in a fucking row.
What's going on now is the Canadians,
they have their, their forwards in their
defense when they're blocking shots,
they, it, the Bruins, just a play
in the dumbest fucking hockey
tickets. Slap shots. There's nobody
in front. He, you go, Carrie,
is there enough ice between me and you
see can get a nice bead on this puck.
Fucking horrific.
And I know a lot of Bruins fans of
pissed that showered in play game too.
They said he was dehydrated
and everybody went,
all these fucking European players
are such pussies. Drink some Gatorade.
I think that that they couldn't say that
he was puking and shitting his brains
out probably, uh, for 24 hours.
I think he had what I
had like a month ago.
So hopefully he'll come back and it'll
crunch another one of those pussy fucking
Canadian players into the boards and
then they can fucking make a goddamn
federal case out of it. Um, I dunno,
the series is not over. There's no
fucking way. There's no way it's over.
I have faith. We got to fucking win. We
gotta win tonight. All right, that's it.
And other than that, I've
just been watching the, uh,
these are my predictions.
I think the lightning are going
to be Pittsburgh. I think. Uh,
I think the Bruins are going to come
back and beat the Canadian sets.
My heart talking flyers.
We'll beat the sabers.
Who else? These are easy to.
Troy's going to be Phoenix.
Vancouver is going to be Chicago
and a way.
What route do you think San Jose is
going to choke this year? Everybody.
Do you think the kings are
going to come back and beat him?
I have no fucking idea. All
right. Let's plow ahead here.
My finals are the obvious. I
think it's, I think the flyers.
No. What about the catalyst? She, the
capitols of finally pushed through.
I got a funny feeling.
The rangers going to beat the capitals.
I felt that even though
they lost game one,
I thought the Rangers were going
to come back and steal game too,
but when they did and they went up two
games to none I, that's when I was like,
ah, I guess the capitals are going to
do it this year, but now that they won
game three, I don't know. I don't know.
There's a lot of pressure on the
capital's lot of fucking pressure on those
fucking cuts in DC. All right, let's plow
ahead here. All right. Uh, very happy.
Stay at home. Dad writes, dear bill,
after listening to one of your recent
podcasts and also watching let it go,
I felt compelled to write in.
I have major issues with stay at home
moms complaining about how hard it is.
Oh Gee, age. Perhaps this
topic has played out,
but I think my situation may
bring a new light on the matter.
I'm a stay at home dad.
I'll spare you how I became a stay at
home dad and just tell you that it's
terrific. I love it. I do all
of what you'd expect. Clean,
do laundry,
yardwork cook homework with the kids
and pickups and dropoffs and have no
problem with any of it. Dude, that
sounds like a fucking vacation.
Wouldn't it be art hanging
out with fucking kids?
I know it sucks when that baby's,
but once they become like,
just like little people,
you know,
and plus all the technology that they
have to fucking in case your children.
You know what I mean?
Just like put up those little barricades
that you can make those little rubber
rooms so they can't hurt themselves.
And then you stick like the teletubbies
on and the lady that's like, you know,
Lsd for kids and they just sit in there
tripping as you're in the other room,
making yourself a little
scotch. Um, anyways. Yeah,
there's no boss.
And every day is like fucking Saturday
you get to hang at your house,
she gets to sleep in your bone bed.
I know the grass is always greener,
but that sounds fucking awesome. Anyways,
she says, I'm a pretty organized person,
so the House always looks good and I've,
oh, and I've always been a good cook.
Now I'm an even better one. My, my,
my wife comes home to great meals in a
clean house and at the end of her day
needs only to eat, relax, and
hang out with our daughter.
Another child is on the way this July.
What does your wife do for a living
that she can, uh, support you?
You guys live in Nice. That's even better
if she's got some insane fucking job.
One of the biggest problems
with my situation is when
she decides to reclaim one
of the traditional female
roles around the house.
This happens periodically about once a
month, usually less. It must be PR, uh,
primitive genetic code that kicks
in every so often. What it does,
my world gets fucked.
Suddenly I'm told nothing is where it
should be in the kitchen and he and I and
we need to organize it or
that parts aren't good enough
or that shit is too high
on the shelves. I have a foot
like a foot taller than my wife.
You know what happened with this,
this reading here,
I was just thinking
how well I was reading.
Now I'm in my fucking head
and I'm screwing up. Just
try to regroup here, Bill.
All right or worse when she decides to
go food come home was shit we don't need
or we have never eaten before because
she felt we should try it or worse yet
when she decides to cook a meal, her
cooking isn't bad, but when she cooks,
I don't get the night off. My job is to
show her where everything is, spices,
dry goods, pots, et Cetera, and also
to reach shit she can, when she's done,
I spend the next day reorganizing
everything to my liking. Dude,
you gotta be like a broad there.
You've got to claim the kitchen
that don't go around moving things.
I have everything where I need it
just shoots. You'll get out of here,
I'll do this. That's what you gotta do.
Your problem is, is you're letting her in.
See Women can shoe guys out of the
kitchen because we don't usually,
most guys don't want to be in there and
in the end we always try to keep it in a
good mood. So maybe you'll blow
us that night. You know, women,
they don't have that kind of sex drive,
you know?
And plus they always have the option of
bag and someone at work if they want to,
you know,
with absolutely no game whatsoever other
than just fucking wearing some hoary
shoes and hiking her skirt up that are
even needed an open in line. You know,
their lives are so fucking easy other
than fucking having to squeeze a kid out.
That's the one thing I'll give
you those nine months of hell.
But you get paid back.
You get to tee off 12 to fucking 20
yards in front of me at the golf course.
People hold doors for you.
You don't have to pay for a movie.
You show a little cleavage,
you get free drinks all night.
What the fuck are you broads bitching
about? All right, plow ahead here. Um,
so anyways, he goes, I don't go to her
office rearranging Shit on occasion.
On the occasions I dropped by.
Oh Jesus.
So don't laugh at me when I tell you
certain things go in certain areas of the
fridge and wide sneeze. Oh No, I do it. I
totally get it. I'm not giving you shit.
He said, I used to complain
out loud to her about it.
Now I just grin and bear it on occasion.
On occasion it happens.
I figured it's better not to rock,
rock the boat less.
She wises up and sees how good I have it.
Dude,
you live in the fucking life.
You know what you are, dude.
You're basically retired
and your wife is out there.
Yeah,
providing your your pension.
I think that's phenomenal.
I think that is absolutely phenomenal
and I don't know why more women don't
enjoy being stay at home. Mom said, I'm
not trying to be as chauvinist pig here,
you know? Okay. Those first
few years suck without a doubt.
But then you've got to understand
once they, they, they go to school,
all right,
late.
They take start going to school
at nine and they get off at three.
You got six hours in the middle of the
day to do whatever the fuck you want to
do and you know something.
And that's one of those classic points
that you bring up to women or stay at
home moms and they freak the fuck
out. And then they go, oh, you know,
then they try to make
those six hours difficult,
like all the fucking shit they have to
do. It's like, what do you have to do?
What exactly do you have to do?
You got the kids dressed and you fed him.
Now he's just fucking school.
Someone else's watching the
kid for the next six hours.
What exactly is it that you
have to fucking do laundry?
Oh my God,
that that's gotta be so difficult
to separate whites from the darks.
Stick it in a fucking machine and press
a button and have it clean it for you.
Where? Where is the, you just, if,
if those six hours aren't enough for you,
you're just creating work for yourself.
You know,
you can actually be sitting on the
couch drinking a margarita as a machine
washes the fucking clothes.
It's not that big a fucking deal.
It really isn't.
Go out food shopping and you get to
go out during the day when there's no
traffic and there's nobody around.
You go to the post office.
He just sort of putz around town.
Your little Mayberry town.
That's a fucking dream, you know? I Dunno.
I just think that,
you know,
that just seems like a
fucking awesome life.
And then the kids come home and it gets
loud or whatever, but they, your kids,
you love them.
You make them fucking sandwiches,
you know? And then, then what? I
mean, how much longer do they go?
You put into bed by fucking eight.
They get home at like, what, three 30
I just don't understand what, what,
what, what the big fucking deal is.
I just don't get it. I really
don't get it. Somebody, please,
if you don't understand,
if every fucking day,
that's another thing too. And the at
the, at the end of all of that bitching,
it's like, well, you didn't
have to be a mom. You know?
It's very easy. There's
condoms, there's the pill,
there's a whole bunch of prophylactics,
all different kinds that
you can choose from.
You fucking chose the job and
now you're bitching about it.
What is your fucking problem?
Jesus Christ. If you want,
you don't want to go food shopping,
just go buy a jar of peanut peanut
butter in a big giant jar of jelly,
peanut butter jelly sandwiches.
They you go bang.
You could do that like three,
four times a week.
They don't give a fuck big glass of milk,
some cheese and crackers.
Why? You're overthinking it ladies.
You're over fucking thinking that.
I really don't.
I don't think it's so fucking hard.
I think you guys are full of Shit.
You know what it is?
Just like how this guy said at the end
of his email where he's just sitting
there grinning and bearing it and he
doesn't want to rock the boat less.
She wises up to see how good he has it.
I think that that's why
those stay at home moms.
I'm not talking about working moms
and talking about stay at home moms.
I think that that's why they complain
that much. Um, the only complaint
there are aspects.
I do understand the fact that you guys
sit there and talk and Gugu Gaga talked
the whole fucking day and you just
want to hang out with an adult.
At some point that would drive me
a little bet shit. But you know,
everything has its ups and downs and I
just don't see the fucking downside is
being that that steep with that job.
I really don't.
Um, anyways, sitting, they
make it macaroni trees
get out,
taking them to the fucking playground
and pushing them on a swing. I mean,
how difficult is that?
That's difficult.
That's harder than sitting in a cubicle,
having somebody coming over
and telling you what to do.
Did you ever think what's great about
being a stay at home mom is you're your
own fucking boss. Nobody's telling
you what to do. Nobody's 10.
Don't even fucking tell me your kids
are telling you what to do. Okay?
Get your Goddamn kids in order. All right.
That's what they invented sticks for.
You know,
slap him around a little bit.
You put the fear of death in them
and then they shut the fuck up. That's
what my mom used to do. She had a paddle.
My Dad went to who was a
member of a fraternity.
He saved the paddle and we would decks.
My mother would line all of us up and
she beat the shit out of all of us.
And you just be standing there in line
waiting for the fucking beaten to come.
Right.
Then you'd always try to block it with
your hand and fucking smashing knuckles
and then she'd send us all the bed.
That was like her break.
She do that once a day and like the
afternoon, that was her afternoon break.
She'd send us to bed and
then we'd go upstairs crying,
all sweaty and crying and shit and sticky
from whatever the fuck we just spilled.
That caused her to kick the shit
out of us. And then, you know,
we'll be up there 10 minutes,
then we just fall asleep.
That was it.
I ain't, what the fuck I'm talking about.
All right. As Bill Promise. You say, Bill,
I'm a senior in high school and have
not been to any of my school functions.
I've been there, sir. I've
been there. I didn't go there.
I went to my senior prom. I didn't
go to any of the other ones. Uh,
I was a fucking orange haired freak
in high school. Um, and I didn't,
I didn't even have the
courage to ask anybody out.
I just saw what was in the
mirror and I was just like,
I'm not going to do this to somebody else.
Why would I put this on someone else?
Um, I have never been to a school dance
and only a few football games at my high
school career.
Dude,
did I write this in a drunken stupor at
that sounds like my high school career.
Next week is the prompt for my school.
And I was wondering if I should go.
I know people say I should go and it would
always be a special moment in my life,
but uh,
will,
it really is prom overrated dude.
You know what?
This is a fucking depressed
individual. You know, dude,
you want to go and now you're going to
sit there. You're seeing order it. Dude,
you're too fucking
smart for your own good.
He can sit there and you're
going to break down the prom.
How fucking stupid it is and the dumb
songs and the Dj and how you never,
you know,
it's senior year.
You're never going to see these people
again your life anyways. Should I not go?
Dude, you should definitely
go get the up to ask somebody.
It's a great exercise because someday
you're going to see a girl that you're
going to want to talk to. You want
to have a couple at bats? All right,
so just fucking ask someone to the prom.
Go get dressed up. Take the
pictures, have a good time. Don't,
don't do what you're doing, dude.
You're, you're overanalyzing life.
You're going to start pulling back from
the herd and you're going to end up like
me,
some psycho babbling to himself and
it takes you 20 years to get it right.
Took me 20 years before he met Nia and
I finally got it fucking right and I'm
starting to function like a human being
and thinking about having kids and
having a dog. I'm telling you,
man, I'm telling you. All right.
It's, it's a part of growing
up. It's a social thing.
It's very important.
I think it's very important to go to your
prompts and your social events because
that's what life is about.
There's a great documentary out
there on Hbo called his way.
I am really bad with names.
It's about this really successful a
Hollywood producer. And as I watched it,
like I saw life lessons that I
learned only recently in life.
And I realized how backwards I had life
when I was a loner because that's not
what life is about. Life is about
networking, hanging out with other people,
laughing with other people,
and becoming successful in life is all
about your ability to connect with other
people and a, so you got to start as
young as possible, man, you still young.
I would definitely do that then,
you know, and uh, that's it man.
I would definitely, I would
debt, oh, he asked me some odd,
did you ever go to a prom and
wasn't magical? No, it wasn't.
It should've been,
but it wasn't because I was a Waldorf
psycho and I apologize to the woman that I
went with. Um, I was just like
you, I was sitting there, um,
when I read the rest of us here,
I was thinking about going,
but then came to the collusion conclusion
of going by myself would just be, oh,
I was thinking of going by myself,
but then came to the conclusion that going
by myself would just be awkward. Yeah,
dude, you don't want to do that.
You're going to freak people out.
People are going to feel bad for you.
And then the mean people are going to
teach you and it's just going to suck and
then you're gonna want to come back like
Carrie and kill everybody. It's just,
it's a bad road. Um, she
says, so if I don't go,
what should I do? Dude,
go. Just go. Definitely go.
You want to go? I'm telling
you. If he didn't want to go,
you wouldn't be asking me. Just
definitely go. Just ask somebody.
I know there's some girls left.
Ask sooner rather than later.
And you know what dude?
Aim High.
Who gives a fuck if she says no, fuck
her. She probably just end up being some,
some fatty at a reunion. One day. This
is now when you want to go in there,
just I'm telling you, you'd go
there, psych yourself up. Aim.
I ask a girl that you think is
out of your league. You know,
take it to the prom maker, fucking laugh
and then see if you can a, you know,
a little something might happen. Who gives
it and if it doesn't, who gives a shit?
Who gives a shit? Sunday when you see
your dream girl sit there and Applebee's,
you'll have the balls to go up to her
cause you fucking talk to that cut in high
school. All right, there's my advice.
All right, let's move on here. Uh,
number two friend is going to be a
dad trying to get him to kill it.
Wow. Wow. Okay. Wow.
We're already at an hour here.
This is going to be a long podcast.
A friend is going to be a dad
dash trying to get him to kill it.
Oh Jesus.
Here we got bill.
My friends got himself into a
shitty situation recently. Gee,
I wonder what this is.
I'm really interested to hear
if you have any advice for him.
And what you have to say.
I got a call from him about a month ago
and said he was going to be a father.
This is the last thing I expected to hear.
He's 26 and pretty much just
started getting laid. Are
you fucking poor bastard?
See? See this. This is another reason
why you want to go to your prom,
cause you don't want to be this guy.
The Guy who first gets laid at
fucking 26 doesn't know anything.
I just fucking dumps his load in the
first fucking stupid waitress. He fights.
This is a very sad thing to happen to
one of your best friends. It really is.
What Saturday is the girl? He knocked up.
What's sad or is the girl he knocked up?
Oh my God, this is depressing me. Uh,
she's not someone you'd
want to mother your child,
let alone be attached to for the rest
of your life. She's a nice enough girl,
but a little off.
She admittedly has some issues in
her head and loves pills in weed.
A little too much. Oh my
God, what did this kid do?
Let alone she is secretly
married to someone.
What
Dude? Are you sure he didn't want
to send this to Jerry Springer?
I don't really know this story,
but let's assume he is foreign
and there is no love involved.
Oh, an arranged marriage is that we
have saying anyway. When I got the call,
my friend,
uh,
you spelled the word wrong,
I guess respectively
repetitively was at the barn.
And what word you're trying to say?
That my friend was at the bar and
yelling about how he wants to kill it.
Um,
I take it you're against
abortion considering you're
saying kill it or are you
just trying to be funny?
Uh,
a day or so later when
our buddies get the news,
we all meet up with him to have a
convince your friend to have an abortion
dinner. Uh Oh,
I see what you want. One of your buddies
were down there talking about it.
They want to kill. All right, so you're
going to sit down with him to, okay.
All right. Here we go. He now has
given up and it's going to have it.
He said he tried talking to her a few
times about getting an abortion and she
won't have it.
She wants to have the kid and every time
he brings it up she hangs up on him or
won't answer his calls
and avoid him for days.
So now in defeat he's going to
have the poor kid. Well you know,
that's one of the things there.
It's not the guys choice,
which is funny when they sit there and
they say proach are you pro choice?
You know that that's not for the guy.
The woman decides unless you're
really smooth talker. Um,
I really think about having the kid will
make her feel some sort of self worth
and that's why she
wants to have it so bad.
My friend is a sweetheart and I have
no doubt he'll be a good father,
but it's situation sucks.
We keep telling him that he'll be attached
to this girl forever and he really
needs to talk to her and
that will even talk to her.
And of course a bunch of us pushing her
down a flight of stairs. Jokes followed
God.
Now he is going with her
to get an ultrasound and
stuff and won't even talk to
us about it. I don't know how
this stuff works, but she does,
but she's about two months preggers and
we think he has a month left to get rid
of the thing. What can he do and
what can we as friends do to help?
Um,
uh,
you know what guys? He's going to
have the fucking thing. I would say,
I would say leave them alone and just
support him and tell him whatever he does,
do not marry this woman.
Okay. He fucked up.
He got her pregnant. She wants to
have it. He doesn't have a say in it.
And uh, that's it. It's
going down. It's going down.
So
you know, he fucked up,
you know, that's life.
Do you know you fuck you? Sometimes when
you fuck up, you don't get a do over,
which is basically what an abortion is.
Uh, she's not going for the duo over.
She's like, Nope, this is the game
plan and we're sticking with it.
Just like the Rangers, even though
people are breaking their fucking ankles,
they're going to keep trying to block
shots. All right? That's what she's doing.
She wants to have the kids. So now
he just has to go with it. And, uh,
this is what he has to do. Never
move in with her. Never marry her.
Don't do anything like that.
She's going to be a single mother.
He's going to be a baby daddy. And, um,
what he needs to do now is he needs to
buy a fucking lifetime supply of condoms.
Uh, he needs to go out and find the woman
that he's supposed to knock up in Mary.
And in the meantime,
support that kid.
That's what he has to do because he busted
a nut in her and she's keeping it so
he's fucked.
He's fucked when it comes to that.
But his life is not over.
He can,
he only has to deal with this
bitch for 18 fucking years.
He has to deal with this kid for life.
I think what he should do is the
kids should be the priority. Um,
he should come to some sort
of zen realization that
he's not going to convince
this woman not to be a fucking maniac
if she is a psycho, like you said.
Uh, what I would do is I try to convince
her not to smoke weed or take any pills
during the fucking pregnancy. Um, and,
and that's it.
I mean,
his only other route is if maybe
she wants to put it up for adoption,
but it doesn't seem like she
wants to do that. But, uh,
he just needs to settle into the
fact that he's having a fucking kid.
But what you guys need to make sure is
that this woman does not talk him into
getting married and being legally,
he, all he has to do is plate pay,
child support.
If he gets married to her now you talk
in alimony and all that type of shit.
And then when he wants to start his family
with the fucking woman he wants to be
with, that's going to be a fucking
nightmare. So, uh, that's it.
All right. So that's what I would
do. I would just say, listen,
just support them as a friend and say,
dude,
if you ever fucking bang
another girl without a condom,
I am got a,
I'm going to disown you.
I'm going to disown you
because it's killing me.
Watching you go through this shit.
So just make sure you fuck the abortion.
He's not doing it.
They haven't the kids.
So now what you gotta do is do not
marry this woman. Do not marry her.
And uh, and that's fucking it.
That's it man. That's a brutal,
brutal, brutal fucking
situation. They are.
But for the grace of God, I'm
anyways, here we go. Let's
read this guy from London,
Guy from London, look at us all
the way across the fucking pond.
Needs advice about girl with STD.
Jesus Christ.
You guys are fucking killing me this week.
I'm a Londoner who just discovered your
standup podcasts. I've got to tell you,
you one of the best can be. Thank
you man. That's fucking awesome.
You know great debt is to
hear from another country.
You make me laugh from
the pit of my stomach,
which is a pretty special
gift to give someone, so thank
you. Thank you. All right,
let's see if I can help you out of
your fucking problem here. Anyway,
I'm writing you because I
just joined a dating website.
I don't know how you
feel about online dating,
but my opinion has always
been that it's fucked up.
Who needs to join a website to get laid?
Who isn't in some way a fucking lunatic.
Right. Um, I think that's the
way it was in the beginning,
but now it's becoming this phenomenal
way of avoiding a cover charge and having
to buy somebody a drink and just going
right towards the chick you want.
Uh, Nino. What's going on?
My girl just walked in
fucking brutal questions this
week. You want to hear that?
Just the titles of these questions?
Uh, or just one in general? Um,
I guess it was just this one friend is
going to be a dad trying to get him to
kill it. Yeah. Okay.
All right. Now I already answered
it. I just thought she, you know,
that that whole pro choice
thing are you pro choice.
That choice is really the woman's, you
know, if she wants to vacuum it out,
like the hoovers getting
turned on and, uh, if, if,
what, could you not say it like that?
When a guy makes a joke like that,
even though you've never had a kid,
do you still feel a little quivering
in there? No, I do not. No, you do not.
What other disgusting question. You look
really good. Thank you. Good deal. Um,
you want it,
you want to help me with this one guy
from London needs dating advice about girl
with this CD. Okay. So
anyways, uh, so he, he,
he always thought the online dating things
for those online dating websites were
just filled with a bunch of psychos
cause who can't just get laid.
But at this point, I think
it's normal now. Yeah.
It's totally normal now to do
online stuff. It's not like,
I don't think there's a stigma attached
to it anymore. People do it well.
I think there's an STD attached to
it. Let me read the rest of this. Uh,
so I'd avoided it, uh, being more than
capable of hooking up in real life.
But my problem is that for about two
years now, that's all I had been doing,
hooking up dating, meeting girls
who never do that thing to me. Oh,
nobody that he falls in love with.
I feel like a Husk,
a 31 year old. I don't know what
that means. Guys from London.
I guess that means like the old guy at
the bar, 31 year old and I'm dead inside.
Oh,
I see.
He's dead inside because no girl can
make me feel how I used to in the school
playground. Oh, with
the first crushes star.
The thing that makes you want to make
pancakes in the morning for a walk through
the park or put on some
Lionel fucking Richie.
All they want to do is come home lately.
Uh,
I want to do after I come lately is wash
her off my dick and bouncer out. Yep.
Yeah, I've been there, which
is no way to live. What? Nia.
I banged a lot of broads before
I met you and that was the thing.
You were like the second year did you
jumped up? You said, hang on a second,
let me get,
let me,
you act like you were getting something
for her and you went in and she figured
it out when she heard the sink was on
too long that you had your Dick and you
are washing it up.
I say is take the hand fucking soap and
it just fucking act like I was jerking
off with soap and that's why I
have the clean cock I have today.
All right. Plowing ahead the thing that
makes you want to blah blah, blah, blah,
blah blah. Okay. Uh, which is no way
to live. I'm actually a romantic guy.
I cry at Disney movies at Jesus do it.
I don't want to read this shit. I fall,
I want to fall in love again. It sounds
like lyrics to a Lionel Richie Song.
It's 2011 people join these sites.
So I made a profile anyways,
this is a fucking long ass
email. Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
Okay. So anyway, she's on this fucking
website anyway, after two weeks,
I'm probably thinking about
shutting down the profile.
The only notable exception so far
being a divorcee, who does yoga?
She invites me to a bar.
We have a drink.
She complains of being tipsy and needing
to drive. I asked what she wants to do.
She corks up the bottle.
It takes me back to her place
and literally takes a run at me.
It was nuts to kind of seedy,
like she'd watch some porn after this.
After the split with her husband decided
that that was the way the world was now
and decided to emulate it for real. So
I'm banging a mature, granted, pretty hot,
mature woman who's looking at me
with this angry look on her face.
That porn star fuck face thing.
That makes me feel uneasy all
ready while saying things like,
do you like that? Huh? That tick
is nicer. Warmer my pussy. Huh?
Jesus Christ.
Are you going?
Are you going to blow your nuts
right inside this pussy? Yeah.
And she's seen it with the English
accent too. That's fucking hilarious.
And I'm just feeling a bit
sad and signed side as I nod.
Anyways, this is the thing. I meet this
girl 26 beautiful and I made beautiful.
She looks like a little Elf or something
that just made it creepy and angels
smoking and she's smart, funny,
Kooky, but in a good hot way.
Probably that dangerous going
to break your heart way too,
but I'm a sucker for that. Anyway,
we go for a walk around the zoo.
Not really given a shit about the animals
because we're too into each other like
a, hey, look, an aardvark. Oh,
you have really pretty hair.
It was great. I'm not the,
I'm not a bad person. After all, my
heart is beating again for this girl.
I feel happy. Whizzy STD thing here.
All right, so we leave the zoo,
go to the bar for a kiss. It's
amazing electricity. Then she goes,
I've got to tell you
something. Oh Jeez. Here we go.
Here we go.
You got to admit,
at that point you were worried
that she had a dick. Right?
There's something I have to tell you.
Um,
I have three nipples and I'm married
to seven different men in Iraq. Uh,
which is the sentence you don't want to
hear on a first date, blah, blah, blah.
So she, anyways, oh no, I
just looked ahead. Oh, Jesus.
Brace yourself. I look
at her and I say, go on.
And she goes on to tell me that a few
months ago she was seeing some guy who
went down on her and it
turns out she had a cold,
he had a cold sore on his
mouth and now she has herpes.
Ugh.
So she's got an incurable STD that
can be passed on at any point.
What do I do about that?
Obviously I get the hell out.
I should be running as far from her
pussy as I can. Right. But I like her.
I haven't liked anyone like this for a
long time, but I also never had a disease.
I look at my shit in that. I look,
I look after my shit in that way.
So I'm in a dilemma. I like
her, but she's damaged. She's,
she's a bit of a skank in the past,
possibly.
But she did the right thing and
laid that on the table for me.
What should I do? I'm clouded right
now. How much am attracted to her?
I need you to help bill. Um, yeah.
You get get the fuck out. Get Out.
Get Out. Get Out. Yeah,
you'll meet another girl too.
You don't need to do that.
Listen, she fucked up. You didn't fuck
up. No, no, no. I, I'm saying my shit.
She didn't fuck up.
Someone gave her an STD.
And how do you don't know how she got
the STD? That's just a story she told.
Well either way like that should happen.
It's not like a,
it's on a death sentence and B,
you shouldn't judge people because
they have an STD. Let me ask you Steve,
let me ask you a question.
She takes her meds,
she is on top of it and make sure that
you know, she doesn't have any breakouts.
If she does,
she does what she needs to do and they
use protection the entire time and he
goes to his doctor and consult about,
listen, my girlfriend has this,
I don't want to catch it.
What can we do or he finds some of with
the clean pussy that makes his heart go
pitter patter
and all.
I don't think it's right to be like no,
stay away from her because she has herpes
because it's like people have STDs.
It's not, listen, if you want to
find the right person to life,
you got to be selfish and I don't know
anybody who has on the list when they
think of this soulmate. Nobody
has herpes. No, of course not.
In an ideal world,
you're both clean. Yeah.
In an ideal world you don't have
sores on your genitalia. I know,
but sometimes that shit happens and
like this is what they need to do.
They need to have a herpes social network
and people can just meet each other on
the herpes social network and they can
just pass it back and forth to each other.
They don't have to worry about
it. Yeah, and then they can,
they can go halvsies on their
herpes meds and it's all good.
It's all good. Think halvsies is,
I'm preaching STD segregation.
I'm reaching out separate
but equal social website.
I think it should be tolerant and I
think he should talk to her about it.
She probably knows everything that she
needs to do in terms of medication.
I think you're full of shit. I think
if the guy had sores on his dick, he,
you'd be like, you'd be like, girl,
can you start rolling your head
like you're on a talk show?
You need to get out
debt. Shit, no, I wasn't
really like the guy or girl. Then you
should just talk about it. You know?
What do they say?
Like in Manhattan,
like one in three people has an STD
now please don't quote me on that.
I could be wrong,
but something insane where like
STDs are like through the roof.
So obviously you should do everything
in your power to protect herself.
But again,
he's also just dating this girl.
He doesn't have to sleep with her right
away. Then there's no fucking point.
There's no fucking point as a guy,
see how it goes and you let me finish.
There's no point.
There's no point in being with a
woman unless you're going to bank.
There's no fucking point.
Well, I understand that.
But they could have like
an open conversation about
that and go to the doctor
together.
They can like they can have a mature open
line of communication about it. Look,
I'm not sure if you actually, if you
feel like this girl is the one then,
I mean that's pretty powerful.
The fact that she has herpes and
you're still being like, you know,
but I've actually, and
he, hey, easy, easy,
easy up and down fucking Camden
street or any, and he's been careful.
He's been careful. He kept his
breastplate on, he fucking had his,
his condom on can catch an STD,
especially through oral sex because how
many people are using condoms when they
go down on a guy and how many people are
using dental dams? Nobody. Can I, can I,
can I give some one night happens.
So if you're going to be
doing that kind of stuff, yes.
One needs to be aware that
that could happen. All right,
I'm going to give some one night stand
advice from a dirty, filthy old man.
All right, one nice Dan
in seven years. So what?
So what I saw about it. You don't
have it anymore. You're done baby.
I got you. It's over all. Wait
a minute. This is what you do.
One of the first things you want to do is
you want to romance to, so you get out,
you get, you get out your George
Michael, a cassette tape. No,
this is the thing, okay? Certain things
don't change. Certain things don't change.
Okay? One night stand. You
never ever, ever repeat.
Ever go down on somebody. You don't do
anything. Okay? I don't even kiss him.
One night stand. You go in, you talk
shit. You pull the fucking hair,
you bend them over and you put on a condom
and you bang them. That's what it is.
What am I trying to fucking
be a gentleman? We're here
to fuck. We are fucking,
you do it. Just the way prostitutes,
dude. That's why prostitutes,
you know that there's no fucking
kissing anything. Did you want to bang?
You put a condom on and you just
do the act. You don't fucking,
you don't try to sit there
and impress him with,
what do you mean in your port
on garden gardener gloves.
You finger pop them a little bit
and this isn't helping this
guy. Don't ever, don't ever,
I'm trying to help other guys.
Don't ever go down on a
woman you don't know ever.
You shouldn't do it ever and you should
wait until you guys are in a serious
relationship and then have her get tested
and make sure that that that lamb may
finish, that you're not going
down on a God damn sewer.
Yeah. The same thing with the
same thing with women guys.
What guys stick their dicks.
Half them joined frats.
They had a fucking ox at some point or
some sort of farm animal. You never,
oral sex is for someone you're in
love with. I didn't give a shit.
If you fucking into it, you
just, you don't do it. Okay,
so you can avoid something like this.
So this is what I would say. Listen,
if you think this girl is the one then by,
I was just trying to be funny.
That by all means. I guess, you know,
do it, but you're also early, early.
You said it, you already said it. I don't
need to say it again. People heard it.
There's a rewind button. Um, I'm an
I'm an I'm an hour. Well go grab it.
Grab a Mike. They're right
there in the closet. Yeah.
Why don't when you walk in here,
just come in with a mic and
be prepared for the Gig. Um,
yeah, don't ever go down on
somebody in a one night stand.
I really need to make that into a
bumper sticker. Um, last question.
If you really liked, I said,
if you really likes her then,
then definitely pursue it. But you know,
also, do you want to deal with this shit?
You know, it's got understand that you
fall in and out of love with somebody in a
relationship and when you
fallen out of love with her,
when you're really getting mad, you're
going to be thinking, herpes shit.
You fucking cold sore
fucking motherfucker. You
give me thinking crazy shit.
Just don't. I mean if you're
gonna pursue her or whatever,
don't be using that is in
your back pockets a thrown
in our face because like I
said,
anyone can get an STD at any time.
It doesn't mean you're a
slut or you're a dirty guy
that does a bunch of stuff irresponsibly.
Sometimes shit happens,
it's life and other times
you are other times,
other times you were filthy fucking whore,
a man whore or a female horror and what
you do is you got to listen to you.
When you got an STD,
you're fucking damaged goods.
So you got to come up
with the fucking story.
I just go one time told me she had herpes.
She told me she had it on her knee.
She said she was in a hot tub.
She told me,
she told me she was in a hot tub,
someone in their hat,
she scraped her knee and she just got
it on her knee and as long as she didn't
in those quadrants of nerves,
as long as she didn't stress
it wouldn't fucking move.
And gradually she starts telling me more
of the story and it magically moved up
to her fucking VGG.
Yeah,
she had fucking genital herpes
and she didn't fuck it. Tell me.
Fortunately I work God damn condom.
And the second she told me the nice story,
I was like shoving off to buffalo,
shoving up the buffalo low.
You know everybody, if you're
out there that you, you
know, you, you run into shit.
Okay. But that's why you always wear
a fucking condom. Always. Always.
And yes,
and guidance.
A lot of guys out there who can't fucking
maintain a fucking erection because
they're so used to raw dog
and that if you put that on,
it feels like they're wearing
a winter coat. All right?
This is what you gotta do.
Don't jerk off for a few days and then
try it. Cause then you're just be site.
Anything is even remotely touching you
down there or rub one out with a conduct.
Just get used to it. It sucks.
But I'm telling you this,
it's gotta be nothing worse than
fucking waking up and having that shit.
You know, core is, it's terrible. And you,
and she probably feels really bad and
embarrassed about it, so it's like,
I don't know. And she could also be lying
how she got it. She could be like him.
She could have been a fucking whore
going out bang and everything.
And that's how she got it.
Yeah. Here and you're right.
And people need to take responsibility.
If you get herpes,
you need to take like 50% of it.
You're 100% right. But I'm just saying,
I would just feel bad if someone was like,
oh, I have herpes and nobody, you know,
wants to be with me, even though I'm
trying. I know you're right. I'm trying.
I'm trying to be funny.
I'm out trying to find balance to try
and give this guy some good advice.
Good advice. You know, you
don't have to settle in life,
but if you feel like this person's
the one that definitely pursue it,
but don't be fucking just sitting there.
You know?
The worst way to go into a relationship
is if you feel bad for somebody,
I feel bad. I want to help
them. It's fucking pathetic.
You don't want to do that shit.
You want someone who's your equal or if
not bet aim fucking has was telling this
kid he wanted to go to a prom.
I go fucking definitely go to your prom
and as some girl that you think Saudi
eleague, that's how you improve
your life. You shoot her.
How the fuck did I ended up with you?
Yeah, I'm definitely out of here. Oh,
I had low self esteem that night and I
was just like, ah, fuck it. I'll, Nah,
I'm just joking. We are an hour
and 23 minutes into this podcast.
I haven't even talked about the
youtube videos. I got to go.
These are the best fucking youtube
videos that we've had in a while.
A fat kid reviews thin mints,
fucking Hilarious Guy
Throws bike to stop thieves.
These guys,
these guys are stealing like a vesper
and this,
this,
this fucking agent dude just takes
his bicycle and throws it at him.
It's fucking,
it's Chuck Norris to the 10th power.
And then for those guys who love to watch
a baseball manager yell at an umpire,
we have to Wally Backman videos of
him just absolutely losing his shit.
One of the one's hilarious.
Like this guy hits a foul ball on the
other team and they call it a home run.
In this guy, he just comes out,
he's already cursing. What, what,
what the fuck was that? Wasn't even
close. It wasn't even close in.
The empire. Just goes, what are you
talking about? And he just snapped.
What the fuck you're there. What am
I talking about? It's awesome. Um,
and then the last one is a comedian who's
drunk off his ass just talking shit.
Uh, Ryan Mervis, ah, checked that one out.
We're going to put a couple of these
videos up on my Facebook page, uh,
if you want. Then the rest will be on
the, uh, the [inaudible] podcast.com.
If you watch it on my Facebook
page, please click the, uh,
the share button so other people see
it and they get exposed to my comedy.
I appreciate that we have a new,
uh, donation button to the podcast.
If you guys would like to donate
any sort of funds to the podcast,
I would greatly,
greatly appreciate it cause I have
a web guy now who I have to pay.
I have overhead now.
It would be nice if you guys
could a kick at some money there.
I could give him a nice
little fucking salary.
Everything could get a little nicer here.
Yada, Yada, Yada. I'm also on Twitter. Uh,
what, what is my Twitter name at Bill
Burr at Bill Burr is my Twitter name.
I wasn't sure.
That's my handle.
I wasn't sure if that was a at
bill burr or at Berto competence.
My Twitter name is ed. Bill
burr and a that said, go Bruins.
They're going to kick the fucking habs
asked tonight. I'm not being the tip.
You don't want to,
I didn't even read.
I Bet Dan Shaughnessy that
fucking God of misery. I bet.
Now he's writing about hockey.
That's the only store he doesn't know
shit about hockey. I bet if he didn't,
if he didn't give him
Lou Cheech Chara or uh,
or fucking Bobby or I don't
think he could name five Bruins.
I don't think total Ray Borg Cam Neely,
you take all of them out.
That's it. That's a podcast for
this week. Ladies and gentlemen.
I hope you guys had a good time.
Uh, if anybody has an STD out there,
hope that wasn't too fucking harsh. I'm
not blaming you. I'm not being a dick.
Okay? Yeah. Be honest about it. Don't be
a cunt, because that's how you got it.
Cause someone else wasn't fucking, yeah,
that's right. Wrap it up. Wrap it up.
That's the podcast for this week.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].